the following is a conversation with
anthony pompliano
entrepreneur technology investor
prolific writer podcaster and
twitter user on topics of finance
cryptocurrency
technology and economics i highly
recommend
his popular podcast and daily letter
called
the pomp podcast and the pomp letter
quick thank you to our sponsors there
gun muscle recovery device
sun basket meal delivery service
expressvpn and
indeed hiring website click their links
to support this podcast
as a side note let me say that i'll be
having many
conversations in the coming months about
cryptocurrency with people of
all kinds of backgrounds and worldviews
those who are proponents of bitcoin
like anthony nick carter robert
breedlove
alex glastine and many others and those
who are proponents of
other cryptocurrency technologies like
vitalik
buterin charles hoskinson richard hart
sergey nazarov
sylvia mccauley and many others as well
i'm not framing this as a debate
i'm simply looking to explore exciting
ideas
in the space of technologies that could
very well change
human civilization and agi
civilization as well i appreciate that
some communities
are a bit more intense in their style of
communication and
others but i personally am only
interested in open-minded
respectful collaboration in exploring
ideas
i personally try to like to approach
conversations by considering that
i may be wrong about everything and i'm
looking to learn
i won't engage in group think social
signaling
outrage mobs mocking and derision if you
do
i understand it's just not my thing i
send you my
love either way and hope to meet you in
person
over some drinks some good laughs and a
good conversation
one day no matter the difference in
style or substance
we're all just human after all this is
an amazing
ride we're all on together buy the
ticket
take the ride as hunter as thompson said
whether you pay for that ticket
with bitcoin ethereum the dollar
gold seashells a beer or just a
good old smile this is the lex friedman
podcast
and here is my conversation with anthony
pompliano you served in the u.s army for
six years and spent
13 months in iraq in 2008 and 9.
can you tell the story of why you joined
the army and what were
some of the moving difficult and maybe
lasting experiences from the time you
served
sure i joined when i was 17 years old i
needed my parents to uh basically sign
in order to uh to join and uh i
graduated semester early from high
school and i thought i was going to play
football in college and kind of enroll
in the spring semester and when that
didn't happen
basically was working at a chick-fil-a
and quiznos
had in my mind look this is probably not
the uh the path in life that i want
um and so i knew i was gonna go to
college i knew i was gonna go play
football in the fall but i had this
window of time and so i walked into a
recruiting
office and just basically was like i'm
assuming you guys need some help
and uh yeah they gave me the whole pitch
and uh you know give you a signing bonus
you can go jump out of planes and go do
all this crazy stuff
i just said okay let's do it this was
this was close to 911.
this was in 2006 about five years after
so what uh impact i mean do you remember
911 what impact did that have when
you're thinking about this
so i was uh in eighth grade um if i
remember correctly
and i remember being in school
when it happened and uh i walked into a
classroom
and the entire class uh somebody else's
class they were all
talking to the teacher about something
the second that me and a couple other
kids walked in and got real quiet and
the teacher was like hey go back to your
like home room
and so it's just kind of a weird like
what's going on uh and then next thing i
know
they called all the students into the
cafeteria and this is back before you
know every
classroom really had a television in it
and you know cable and all that kind of
stuff
and so when we were there they basically
just said listen there's been this uh
event
that's occurred all of your parents are
gonna come pick you guys up and uh
they'll explain it to you
and so to you know a kid in eighth grade
you're basically like
what happened and so i got home and i
remember talking to my dad about it
and my dad basically gave me you know
the uh
the core american kind of talking points
right somebody from another country
came here and tried to kill americans
and was successful in doing
that um and to some extent he just said
and i'm willing to bet you know we're
going to go back after him did that wake
you up a little bit to the idea that
there's evil out there that
you know even just the idea of terrorism
for many people that was um
when it hits you on your own land it's a
it
really shakes up your mind in some sense
world war ii
that's why world war ii was
fundamentally different for americans
than
it is for people like in russia in
england and france
and in europe in general is
there's something about when there's
families women children dying
on your own land that's different
and that was one of the first times in
america where like on euro
of course it's pearl harbor but like
this is like in recent history
it's like they hit us here
that was like a profound idea i think
america was very very good at exporting
the violence elsewhere for a long time
and uh there was this element of uh
complacency
but also this element of uh um you know
really just american superiority that
doesn't happen here right
and i think that that woke people up not
only to
um kind of the idea that other places
around the world may not like the
american ideals may not like democracy
and capitalism and
and that but also maybe we aren't as
big tough and secure as we thought we
were right and so obviously i think you
see the kind of over
rotation with a lot of the kind of
security theater that came
after that of almost psychologically
let's make our citizens feel
like they're safe even if the things
that we're doing don't necessarily you
know kind of change that apparatus
but on top of that i think that it
really woke people up to
uh extremism around the world and uh
i don't know if necessarily there was a
change in the extremism
as much as it just was an awareness
thing right how many people
you know kind of drew a line from was it
92 or 93 with the
world trade center bombing to you know
deep levels of extremism and hatred of
kind of the american industrial complex
probably not that many 2001
a lot of people and so i think that was
you know again as a young kid
you don't understand a lot of this stuff
you basically just hey somebody came
here and tried to
kill americans and so you know we should
go fight back
right was kind of the the response i
think that i had
what role did that have psychologically
for you when you
then in 2006 joined the army i mean
this is very different joining the army
than
in the time when like it's more peaceful
here you're essentially facing i mean i
don't know if you see it that way but
you know there is a war on terror and i
know that people
kind of uh criticize that whole
formulation framework of thinking but
nevertheless
you are going to iraq you are going to
afghanistan you're
you're going to these places and are
fighting these complicated
like i mean it's not even clear what
you're fighting
yeah well i think there's a couple of
key pieces right so one like one of
the actual most impactful data points if
you were or kind of stories for me
uh was the pat tillman story so i played
football uh in high school and i was
gonna go play in college
um and seeing you know this nfl player
who basically just one day said hey i'm
going to go and do this instead
and walk away i don't know necessarily
if it was a
i want to pursue the same story right
and obviously he
ended up dying and so not exactly the
the end result that you want
but i think it was almost like uh he
made it okay
if you were on a certain trajectory in
life to go take this detour
and and to go do it um but the second
thing is i was 17.
you're pretty stupid when you're 17.
you're pretty naive when you're 17 right
and so uh i almost um kind of backed
into
the deployment because i signed up uh as
a
a reserve member and so basically the
plan was to sign up for the reserves i
was going to go to basic training get
all the you know kind of education and
qualification
i was going to go to college and then
after college you know maybe there's a
chance that you will go and serve or do
whatever
for me i ended up getting deployed when
i was a junior in uh college so i got
pulled out of school
and so at 20 years old it's not exactly
what you thought you were signing up for
right especially to kind of leave school
to go do it and then on top of that
uh i probably had an advantage over most
people both on the
entry to combat and the exit to kind of
a combat situation which
was football so i always explained that
um
in hindsight you're in a male-dominated
testosterone driven kind of combative
sport
where it's us first them and and uh
there's training and
and uh you know injuries and just kind
of all of the things that go into
playing a combat sport like football
to now they give you guns but you still
have a uniform on still male dominated
it's just a little bit you know more
serious in terms of the injuries and and
potential death and things like that but
also on the exit from that deployment
most guys i was there with they're going
back to being you know
prison guards police officers working at
the lumber yard
you know just kind of everyday americans
and so i had the fortunate ability to go
back into
uh kind of that combative environment go
back to play football and so it was
almost this like de-escalation on the
way out
uh where they take your guns away we
still got a uniform still male dominated
uh still combative and then eventually
you're just a normal citizen
and so i think that in some weird way i
was you know very fortunate to kind of
on the
entry and exit have that experience
where other guys didn't
so what you were deployed to iraq
were there any memories experiences that
changed you
or in general like you're probably a
different man on the other side of it
how did that time change you i think
there was two main
takeaways that i took right so one was
um not a specific moment but on multiple
occasions
i remember we were driving down the road
and i would look and there would be a
10 12 14 year old kid and if you've
never seen somebody who
literally has hate and disdain in their
eyes towards you
just not necessarily to you personally
just to the uniform to what you stand
for it's all the stuff
when you see it you see it right and i
always think of um
if you've ever uh watched the movie a 12
strong
and in it they've got this afghan
afghanistan warlord and he's
talking to a bunch of soldiers and he
says you know you don't have killer eyes
you do you do and he's just like he can
just tell right he's seen so many
soldiers
and so i think that that was a a memory
on a number of occasions where i just
saw a young kid
and i just said they hate us right and
and it's not
you personally it's what you stand for
but the the really big event was
when you first get to these combat zones
a lot of times what will happen is
you basically your unit teams up with a
unit that's leaving
and there's a handoff and it happens
over a couple of weeks and so you can
imagine almost
you know one percent of our team goes
out with 99 of their team then 5
95 10 90 all the way till it's 50 50 and
then eventually it rotates and then it's
majority of our team and
a small number of their team and so what
a lot of people will explain is the two
most dangerous times in war
are actually the first two or three
weeks in the last two or three weeks
when you first get there you don't know
who the people are you don't know the
terrain you don't know
you know kind of the local cultures and
who to look out for what signs all that
kind of stuff
and the last two or three weeks is you
basically think you've survived the
deployment you're looking forward to
going home so you become complacent
things like that
and so we made it through that
transition period with no issues
uh but the literally the very first
mission uh that we went out
as a team ourselves 100 um
there was two separate incidents uh one
was we were driving in milanite
and uh what we think was a sniper shot
at
a truck that i was in i was standing up
outside of it along with a
another guy and that was kind of just a
wake-up call again of
never been shot up before right and so
i'll never forget
uh you kind of heard this whiz go by and
the guy next to me was from rural
pennsylvania and he just said
you know look i've never been shot at
before either but i've done a lot of
hunting get the [ __ ] down
okay and so uh we kept driving that
night
um and uh later on in the night uh an
ied went off a guy ran over an ied
uh who was at the front of the convoy
and when that ied went off
uh again i had never been in a convoy
that had been blown up before but the
training kicks in
and so immediately every single person
starts screaming out ied ied and they
start looking and trying to figure it
out and you realize
the united states military did a
fantastic job training us before we went
because in that moment nobody thought
about anything you just did what you had
been programmed to do
and so ultimately kind of through the
end of that event uh there was u.s
soldier that ended up dying he was uh
shot in the head
and um when we got back to the base uh
kind of after that entire event
i think it just hit us we are at war and
if we make mistakes here
that is the cost of you know kind of
those mistakes
and this was somebody who i didn't know
uh it was somebody who literally showed
up
kind of as secondary support for our
unit
and basically uh was there to help us
right and so it was one of those weird
situations where
uh you have this emotional connection
because it's somebody who
uh shared an event with you but you
didn't know them
right and you learn their name later and
you understand that they have a family
and they have young kids and all this
stuff
and so again as a 20 year old kid you're
kind of processing all this and you just
realize like
the gun i have in my arm my hands it's
real for a reason
right and we better take this seriously
this is not you know us joking around
in kind of the barracks and you know all
the things that you would expect
you know guys are doing the army so i
think that was like the moment where i
said
hey i'm going to learn a lot here uh and
i got to make sure i get home
and you snapping into the training but
nevertheless i mean you're somebody who
thinks philosophically about this world
now
right you're uh very intelligent and
thinks deeply about
the world so looking back you mentioned
hatred in the 14 year old kids eyes
there's death so the way you kind of
describe this whole story
is like training kicks in this this [ __ ]
is serious
like this is uh you know there's a
reason there's a gun
in your hand so there's a strategic
element there's like you have to get the
job done there's a task at hand
but at the same time if you zoom out
there's a kid
who has hate for you some of those kids
would probably if they could
would kill you for the thing you stand
for in the uniform
and then there's bullets flying at you
and then there's people that some of
them
you might already care for deeply are
dying
what the hell do you make of that
do you think about that does any of that
haunt you
how do you think about the world having
witnessed that
yeah a lot of times when we would talk
about it we were there
if i was that kid i would want to kill
that person too
right i would have hatred as well right
imagine if in the united states
tomorrow you and i woke up and there was
tanks rolling down the street from
another country
yeah and they were basically imposing
their rules on us
whether they thought it was the right
thing to do or not the soldiers were
there they were doing this
we would probably feel not so great
about it right at kind of a minimum
and at a maximum we'd be really really
pissed off we would fight back
and so what you don't understand when
you're in the heat of the moment is
why does this person feel this way and
so what's very weird
is well what happens if a year ago u.s
soldiers came through
they got shot at they returned fire and
they killed that kid's uncle
you'd be pissed off right and so you
just start to understand like
we look at war very black and white we
look at it very much
from a clinical perspective we're going
to go we're going to go kind of invade
somewhere
we are the most dominant military in the
world we're very good at invading
uh and we will crush wherever we invade
but when you're actually on the ground
what you understand is the humanity of
it all
right and so what becomes very
interesting is uh
pretty much every veteran i know that
comes back they're some of the largest
pacifists in the world
and i always revert back to uh marcus
latrell uh who's a famous navy seal
um and there's a movie made about him
and his story uh he gave a speech one
time
that i saw and he basically said listen
if you're a politician your job is to
be the diplomat do everything you
possibly can not to send me and my
friends
anywhere because when you send us we're
gonna bring hell with us
right and understand that is the
business that we are in
but every single other person up until
we get sent has a job to do to prevent
having to send us
and i think that ultimately that's where
you see a lot of kind of this generation
that is fought in iraq and afghanistan
that says listen maybe we shouldn't be
running around the world being the
police
maybe we shouldn't be going and invading
all these different countries
because when you actually get to see
firsthand what happens
it's just something that we should avoid
at all cost but if we have to go
or we have to actually send soldiers
somewhere
understand what happens when that occurs
and you know the united states is the
best in the world of doing it
do you think i'm thinking about that kid
with a hatred do you think there will
always be hatred in the world
do you think from another perspective do
you think there'll be war
always is that a fundamental aspect of
human nature
or is that something we can escape yeah
so war
i think has like very negative
connotations in terms of bullets and
bombs and death
and kind of just very morbid type um
understanding conflict on the other hand
i think people look at and say of course
there'll always be conflict right you
just can't have
billions of people all on the same
planet without some level of
disagreement whether that's a
disagreement of ideas
disagreement over physical you know
geography or something else and so i
think conflict will always
exist the question is what form does war
take moving forward
and so in my mind you know it's starting
to look a lot more clinical
right a lot more drones a lot less
soldiers on the ground
a lot more use of special forces and
kind of these small highly specialized
teams rather than kind of big mechanical
armies
um and then you get into like the
information warfare and kind of cyber
warfare and you start to understand that
we're at war with a lot of people right
now right doesn't mean we're necessarily
dropping bombs uh on their countries
it doesn't necessarily mean we're
sending soldiers there but on a daily
basis we are engaged in these kind of
you know cyber battlefields and so if
that's where war starts to play out
um it one changes the tools and tactics
and techniques that
we need to arm our country and other
countries will arm themselves with
but it also changes the way that we
think about war right
it see it sounds a lot less uh worrisome
if i say hey
we're going to go to war with a country
but by the way there's going to be no
death
right okay like that doesn't sound
nearly as bad as hey we're going to go
send 10 000 soldiers and you know some
percentage of them are gonna die on the
battlefield and then we're gonna
you know basically pipe back videos and
articles
saying that american soldiers are dying
yeah it does seem to be a fundamental
difference between the
the genghis khan style like if i would
feel
differently if somebody
like hand to hand with a knife murder my
family
versus cyber security where i stole all
their data
stole all their money stole everything
they owned
falsified their identity all that kind
of stuff that
those are both traumatic events
but they do seem to be fundamentally
different but maybe that's
actually very narrow style thinking
because
ultimately you have to think about what
is life and what's happiness
and it's like the samurai thinking
i'm not sure what's more painful if i
take it to myself like i'm not sure what
i would rather
live through being stabbed
like to death or
having my identity stolen all my
money stolen or maybe
reputation destroyed like with lies or
something like that
that that's very interesting to think
about if you think about quality of life
and all those kinds of things
well one that's finite right
yeah and the other is kind of a long
prolonged almost torture
physical pain versus psychological pain
uh it's really interesting to
it's really interesting to think about
and i think another key piece to this um
which i don't have answers to
but but there is an element of emotion
and rage in the physical violence versus
again more of that clinical you know
information warfare and so
um it's really easy to show a
battlefield where there's death on both
sides and
bombs being dropped and buildings
destroyed it it fits very well into
propaganda for everyone involved
right regardless of what side they're on
when you start talking about
cyber warfare how many times have we
seen a big company
get data hacked or information hacked
and we all
you know read the headlines maybe throw
a tweet out and then move on with our
day and don't remember it anymore
and so it's just very very different i
think
in the emotion and response that it
invokes in people when they hear about
it as well
given the conflict do you think people
are fundamentally good
are we all sort of like blank slates
that could be
evil given the environment or good given
the environment
or can we kind of is there some base
that we can rely on that people
if left to their own devices will be
good
and trustworthy and honest i think you
have to separate out intention from
action
so if you talk to some of the most
heinous criminals in the world
they've rationalized their actions and
so you've got to ask yourself
what is the level of which they
understood what they were doing
that they intended to be malicious
nefarious
um and kind of do bad things versus
the actual actions themselves and so um
even as a society you know if let's say
for example
you were to walk down the street and you
were to murder somebody on the sidewalk
completely unprovoked
we would look at you and say you are a
you know a sociopath
uh you have everything wrong with you
and that is somebody that we do not want
in our society and therefore we will
levy
you know the extent of rule of law
against you in order to
protect society from you right you
become that a monster of that beast
if in the same situation somebody walks
in your house with a knife
and you murder them or you kill them
now we put you up on a pedestal as a
hero
and those are two very very different
responses they may be just as morbid
they may be just as violent uh in terms
of the actual actions
the intentions the way it's perceived is
very very different and so
i think that uh as a world we like a
very black and white clean-cut you know
good
bad uh i think the world's a lot more
messy than that and i think that
a lot of times when you look at
intention it's hard for us to tell what
somebody's intention is
but i've looked at a lot of you know
people who are both
considered very good and also a lot of
people are considered very bad
and they sound very similar in terms of
the motivations for their actions
and so i think that it's just a really
hard problem that probably doesn't have
a perfect solution or an answer
do you give much value to the intention
or do you think is is better to look
at the results of the behavior uh as
opposed to the
in the un underlying ideology the
underlying intention
of the behavior i think that intention
gets at the question of like are people
inherently good or bad
yeah right is i think that they're
generally inherently good
and the intention is driving towards the
thing that they believe is the best
outcome or the best thing for them to
pursue the action i think is where we
spend most of our time focused on
and frankly we actually may be a better
society
or kind of kinder as a humanity to each
other
if we spent more time looking at
intention rather than action um but
again
you know if somebody walks down the
street and murders somebody uh it's
really hard to have a conversation and
it may be inappropriate for us to have a
conversation about intention
versus uh any level of of action right
so you're one of the prominent
i would say even the faces of the the
world of cryptocurrency
bitcoin that whole entire world let's
dive straight in and ask uh
do you think do you consider yourself a
bitcoin
maximalist i think that the way i really
look at it is
uh i work backwards off of what is the
maximalism that i believe in and the
world that i believe in
is kind of an automated world that is
run on these open decentralized
protocols
uh and what we ultimately do is we
return
sovereignty and individualism and and
kind of uh personal responsibility and
liberty
uh to people over institutions and what
we end up doing
is we end up uh kind of taking what has
historically been a very
uh analog or physical world economy and
uh
geographic rule and we then kind of put
it in the cloud
and this digital economy becomes the
prevalent way that we all
uh conduct commerce communicate uh etc
and so
it's less about any one single
technology to me right
i think that it's pretty stupid for
people to um almost in a way
uh put an inanimate object up for uh
you know some sort of obsession uh to me
it's much more about the ideals the
ethos
uh and the most rational uh and likely
path
to that kind of end result or that world
that i think you know is at this point
just a foregone conclusion so the
distinction there
and maybe if people don't know the
terminology maximalism is basically
saying i really think this is a good
idea
like uh you know if you prefer a certain
kind of diet
you could be a keto maximalist saying
like this is probably
maybe it's not a hundred percent but
probably the diet that's healthiest for
humans kind of thing
in the same sense bitcoin maximalism is
saying
you know of course we don't know there's
a lot of uncertainty but this particular
technology
seems to be the best representations of
some set of ideals
that defines progress in in the future
but you're drawing a distinction between
sort of uh
cult-like obsession about an object of
any kind whether it's
keto uh or uh bitcoin
and just sort of believing that a
technology is the best representation of
a particular set of ideals
and you believe that sort of uh
this moving into the cloud
both the distributed nature of it but
also just the digital nature of it
is something that's going to uh be a
positive step for humanity
yeah i would even take maximalism a step
further and it's not just the
kind of singular viewpoint of this is
the best
it's also an element of it's
anti-everything else right
so you know take keto for example uh the
keto diet is not only the best diet all
the other diets are bad
yeah right and so it's it's a very
binary view of the world
um i think that what's probably most
misunderstood about
uh let's take bitcoin uh as a specific
example
is that most of the people who are
labeled bitcoin maximalist
they would be open-minded if they
believed that something else came along
that was a superior
technology or had a better kind of
probability of achieving
again that ultimate vision i think where
uh
there's this controversy and kind of
clashing of uh ideas
is that the bitcoin community believes
bitcoin is the best way to do that
and has very specific arguments as to
why the other things are not
right and so what ultimately ends up
happening which is very weird
in uh the investing world right it's
unlikely that you and i are going to sit
down you're like apple stock is the best
stock and there's no other stock that's
worth anything yeah right
and uh and then also it's very weird if
you said to me
um you know this stock is worth zero and
that's where
everything that i own i've put on a
short on one single company
right there's diversification there's
much more kind of probabilistic thinking
in finance in general
uh when it comes to this specific world
of cryptocurrency and kind of digital
assets if you will
uh is there's two main groups of people
who are trying to build two
very very different things at the onset
but when you unpack it and you start to
spend more time on it you guys they're
actually trying to accomplish the same
thing in two different ways
so bitcoin is seen i think as a digital
currency
right kind of the idea that this is
going to ascend to become the next
global reserve currency
it's a programmatic kind of transparent
um money
and uh it's essentially just 180 degrees
difference than the inflationary
you know non-transparent fiat currencies
that exist in the world
you then look at kind of everything else
right and you have a lot of smart
contract platforms and
various things that they're all going
after right ethereum with kind of the
world computer approach and you can kind
of go down the line with all their other
arguments it's what they're trying to
build
i think the big difference just comes
down to uh innovation
for security and when you simplistically
look at it
via that lens you actually
understand where both people are coming
from when you say security start to
interrupt
do you mean financial security or do you
mean like literally the the the security
of the
of the particular cryptocurrency the the
technical security of a blockchain so
when you look at let's say
um bitcoin versus ethereum right bitcoin
has decided and that community has
decided
security is the number one thing that
you have to optimize for so
decentralization
um over everything else in terms of
transaction speeds
cost anything that you could come up
with that is
something that would be important for a
currency the number one thing to
optimize for is security
and as we have seen uh with a lot of
technologies right
facebook's libra or now what's known as
dm is a great example
uh not having decentralization is
susceptible to
the nation state and so a lot of these
other
platforms and blockchains uh they say
security is
important but it's not the most
important thing right we believe there's
a trade-off between
you know a little less security and
transaction speed or
composability or whatever it is and so
take ethereum as kind of the
second uh largest uh community in
blockchain by market cap
it was created because somebody wanted
to or a group of people wanted to do
something on bitcoin they felt like they
couldn't do it and so they said hey
we're going to go create something that
has these smart contracts that we can
then go do here
again this is technology right so the
tribalism of like you're right you're
wrong
to me is a little childish just in the
sense of like the market is going to
decide what is most valuable
and then when you go inside of that
community like there's a lot of dumb
ideas people are trying to build around
bitcoin
there's also a lot of really really
great ideas that people trying to build
around bitcoin
same thing in the ethereum world and so
what you end up getting i think is the
tribalism really comes out of the idea
that there's a ticker price
that is attached to all of this right if
you go back in history of technology
venture capitalists didn't sit around
the table and yell and scream at each
other in this like religious zealot way
right because you bet on one type of
cloud computing platform and i bet on
another one
right it's just the market's going to
decide we're both going to work on and
try to make ours successful
uh here i think that the sensitivity and
mainly comes out of the bitcoin
community
is that a lot of this is being funded
not only by
venture capitalists and kind of
professional money managers and asset
allocators
there's also this element of including
the retail investor
and the public and so it whether it's
through icos or some other forms of
capital raising
there's arguments for it saying hey look
uh this now gives
kind of the little guy some sort of
access and ability to do it
but there's also arguments against it
some people say hey it's easier to dupe
them and it's easier to run scams and
kind of all this stuff and so
ultimately i think that uh crypto is
this like
arena of ideas it is literally the war
of attrition
and uh what will end up happening is ten
years from now you and i will talk
and we're gonna say well the market said
x was valuable and y wasn't
and so all of the tribalism from between
you know here and there
uh it's fun it's you know engaging
whatever but also it doesn't really
matter
yeah because the public is involved
there's a lot of personalities and so
a lot of times we focus on the ex
extreme personalities
that do a lot of maybe uh pardon the
french [ __ ] talking and
and so we kind of focus on that but
that's not necessarily representative of
the
communities involved let's talk about
bitcoin first and then it'll help us use
as a kind of comparison to
ethereum or whatever else so when you
think about what is money
right that's kind of the first question
people really kind of go down the rabbit
hole on and
ultimately today it's a belief system
right and you may believe that one
currency has more value over another
because it's backed by a certain
military or a certain government has
a monetary policy that you believe in or
don't believe in
but ultimately it's a belief system that
there's nothing backing this
other than a government asks you to pay
your taxes in it right
and they can have a monopoly on violence
uh in terms they can put you in jail if
you don't pay your taxes
uh they can go to other countries and
they can invade and do all this stuff
it wasn't always like that right it was
historically
a layer one technology was gold and so
gold
was a fantastic store of value you knew
that if you held gold it wasn't going to
be inflated away it was sound money it
was outside the system and no one could
create more of it
the reason why that's important is
because that optimization for store of
value served as the bedrock
of the entire stack of uh money
uh for 5000 years and so the problem
with that though again trade-off between
store of value
is it was really hard to transact with
right if i came in here
and i and you said hey i want a couple
of ounces of gold and i had a whole bar
i'd have to literally
shave off the ounces of gold uh it's
heavy to carry around if you said to me
hey you're in one city mail it to me
it's really expensive you know there's
all these issues with it
and so ultimately what people said was
well let's create a second layer
on top of that gold in order to make it
easier to transact and so we created
paper claims on the gold so hey don't
carry around the gold in your pocket
anymore
put it in a vault or a bank they're
going to issue a paper claim
now you and i can trade these paper
claims around and at any point if you
want the gold you just show up and you
say hey give me you know three ounces of
gold or two bars or whatever
and so that actually made the store a
value it was
allowed that to be the anchor and kind
of the most important part the security
of
your purchasing power but now it became
easier to transact and then eventually
we built layers even on top of that so
everything from electronic money
uh kind of electronic q-sips all the way
to credit and other systems on top of
that gold
1971 comes around and obviously we d-peg
from that
gold right it was a temporary measure at
the time we ended up not going back to
it
and so what you moved uh or transitioned
from was sound money which was outside
the system no one could create more
to now the government had full control
they could create as much as they wanted
to
they tried to be responsible and
disciplined but obviously hard to do
sometimes we've been really good at it
sometimes we've been less good at it and
you go around the world and
some countries have absolutely sucked at
it and some have been good at it
and so when you look into the bitcoin
world i think that when you look at the
optimization for security similar to
gold store value
people hold it purchasing power has gone
up a lot year over year it's like a 200
percent
year-over-year compounded annual growth
uh for over a decade
right so you measure this in kind of the
us dollar exchange price et cetera
but there's still a lot of people who
will yell and scream about it's slow
it's costly right all the things around
those transactions
that are obstacles or challenges and so
there's basically two schools of thought
and this is where we kind of get into
the bifurcation
some people just said hey this
technology is antiquated we can't use it
it doesn't make sense
uh and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go build something new and so you
go get you know kind of all of the
various versions there
the bitcoin community says no just like
gold had paper claims and other things
built on top and layer two three four
five
we're gonna do that here and so they've
already started to build kind of this
layer two
where it's easier to transact it's
cheaper it's faster etc
and so i actually think that both of
those worlds are gonna coexist in the
future
the big question is just which one has
more importance
right so again get out of binary it's
just probabilistically
and so my personal belief is that the
security the the
store of value component as the bedrock
for a monetary system
is essential right like that is the most
important thing because you can always
improve the other components but you
can't go back and fix that kind of core
piece
so if money money is a an idea that we
all it's like an emergent idea that we
believe in
you're saying that security is one of
the most fundamental catalysts
or fuels for that idea to sort of take
hold
and be stable and sort of take over the
world
the other stuff is really nice to have
but if you don't have the security
you're not going to
like it's not going to spread in a viral
sense in in our
human brains well and especially in
light of
the kind of the macro economy right so
like what's so fascinating about the
last 12 months
is um in investing in general the best
returns right i kind of put that in air
quotes a little bit is something that is
different
than everything else and right so being
different and wrong just means you're an
idiot
right being different and right means
that that's where kind of the outsized
returns are
and so if you look around the world at
currencies today they're all the same
they're all inflationary unlimited
supply controlled by a government
done and decisions made in a very
non-transparent process
and what we've watched is the
manipulation of all of those currencies
over the last 12 months
in direct contrast to that is this thing
bitcoin
which is outside of the system has a
finite supply
transparent and programmatic monetary
policy and so when you see those two
systems
kind of um in comparison to each other
in the united states
there's a lot of people who say the
dollar works great for me i can go to
the atm i can get out physical cash
if i want to swipe a card i could do
that my money in my bank doesn't lose 50
of its value in a day
in terms of purchasing power like the
dollar is pretty good
when you go to other countries that
might not be the case and so i do think
that there's uh kind of a relative
analysis that goes on here if you
compare bitcoin to the dollar
there's all kinds of arguments to make
that the dollar is better as a medium of
exchange today
but if i go and i tell you what about in
you know these kind of extreme
examples of uh venezuela zimbabwe turkey
et cetera
and so i think that that's kind of one
perspective to view this through
is security versus all of the innovative
components of a medium of exchange etc
the second thing though that i think is
really really important is around
censorship
and so when you look at again every
currency in the world today
every single financial service they're
highly susceptible to censorship
and actually i would argue the united
states is in the business
of censorship in terms of you know how
many countries around the world
do we sanction and cut them off in
either a
minimal or a very material way from the
global financial system
so when you define when you talk about
censorship do you mean just the
censoring your ability to operate freely
in the world
well look at it a little bit differently
which is that the united states has
kind of the american superiority because
we have the bombs the bullets the
soldiers and
and that military might we basically
impose our will
around the world and so uh there's a
very strong
argument to be made that there are
certain countries around the world
that are being sanctioned that the
people of those countries
did nothing wrong now the governments
are bad right in terms of the way that
you and i would look at democratic rule
or communism or whatever it is
but the people are being hurt as well so
there's a whole group of people who
would have just argued listen
we shouldn't hurt anyone at the expense
of punishing
one person or a group of people there's
other people who argue against that
but i do think that if you really kind
of zoom out and you say i'm going to
take myself
out of the western world view and i'm
simply going to look at this as we're
all part of the human race
it's censorship and there might be an
argument for censorship
but there also might be an argument
against the censorship and so what
bitcoin
does as that specific kind of payment
network is it says anyone in the world
with an internet connection
i don't care where you are born what
language you speak what religion you are
your wealth status your education status
none of it matters
if you have an internet connection you
can plug into this monetary system
and you can move value around the world
to anyone else without asking for
permission
and in the united states we basically
have that ability in the us dollar kind
of traditional banking system
i can pretty much send money to almost
anyone i want unless they're a really
bad person that's on some list or
something
most people in the world don't have that
capability and so what you're
essentially doing is you're
democratizing access
to a true store value and
a medium of exchange right and so what
you see in many of these countries is
that when their currency starts to fail
the first thing that a government or a
group of people in power and influence
do
is they lock the citizens into the
currency with capital controls
why because if you let them out it
exasperates the problem
and so now what we're seeing is we
basically are giving
a tool to billions of people around the
world that is a peaceful protest
right you and i had no say at all
when not only the federal reserve and
elected officials here in the united
states
but central banks around the world over
the last 12 months decided to create
trillions of dollars and inject it into
the monetary system
right they have arguments and some of
them are very good arguments as to why
they should do that they're trying to
mitigate short-term pain
long-term they'll figure out the other
issues right they have very kind of um
elaborate and well-articulated um kind
of viewpoint as to why they're doing it
but you and i had no say and so when you
start to look at
we have a very small group of people in
this world uh both in our country and in
countries around the world
that make these decisions that have very
very far-reaching kind of impact
and on top of that in many cases there's
actually not
that much kind of accountability because
usually these are not
elected officials who are making some of
these decisions these are appointed
you can argue that hey we elected
somebody who appointed them but at the
same time
that accountability isn't quite there
and so i think ultimately when you just
back out you say you know what is
bitcoin and why is it important to the
world
it is giving access to anyone in the
world with an internet connection to a
store of value
and a monetary network that allows them
to peacefully protest and to
opt out of a system that
pretty much is not working for majority
of people in the world
so it's moving the power from these
centralized places sometimes unelected
to the individuals and to the people
so the dollar does seem to work for for
americans
and for many people in the world but you
kind of have a vision you
you paint a picture of a future where
potentially we move to cryptocurrency so
what kind of trajectory do you see where
bitcoin can become the main currency
in the world or at least cryptocurrency
become the main
way of storing value in the world and
basically overtake the dollar
yeah so i always go first to we don't
need to have
competition like in terms of like a
direct competition between the dollar
and bitcoin right if you look at most
technologies in the world
uh the really valuable ones are actually
market expanding technologies
rather than simply just market share
stealing technologies
right so if you look at uber for example
uber didn't just say hey i'm going to go
take out all the taxis right it actually
drastically expanded the market for
people now there's literally millions of
people
in the united states who don't have cars
because they use uber right and so i
think that bitcoin is very similar
in that yes there is a component of
medium of exchange
uh in terms of the dollar but also there
is this component of just store value
assets in general
and so when you start to look at bitcoin
specifically i think that what you're
seeing is you're seeing a generational
gap
where young people say i grew up with a
phone in my hand i'm digitally native
the whole idea of going to the bank and
sending a wire
or going to an atm and getting physical
cash is an antiquated idea in their mind
right i one time asked my brother he's
24 years old and i said hey how do you
send money to your friends
and he gave me one answer which i
expected which was venmo and the second
answer i didn't expect he said uber
i said how do you send money via uber he
said well we get in a car together and
at the end we split the ride
and so again you and i have probably
both done that but i never thought of it
as a way to send money to each other and
so it is a
psychological difference between even me
who's only you know
a decade older than him or so uh and his
peer group and so i think as we're
watching kind of bitcoin
continue this ascent ultimately what
we're seeing
is an entire generation of kids are
saying listen if i look at
financial assets across the board i have
stocks i have bonds i have currencies
and i have commodities
i know that bonds from a real rate
return perspective
is flat to negative right i'm going to
make no money on this because
i have a belief that my dollar is being
devalued
and actually what we're starting to see
is again the internet has broken down
these walled gardens and kind of these
centralized uh hubs of information
in that if you were to look at let's say
the stock market from 1971 to today
in dollar terms it's a 45 degree angle
right up into the right right you know
it's kind of seven
eight ten percent growth uh every year
and it's amazing just get invested in
the stock market and you'll make money
over a long period of time regardless of
the dips along the way
if you denominate that same stock market
in gold the stock market is down since
1971.
and so is it so much that the stock
market is accruing true value
or is it that the underlying currency in
which it is denominated in
is being devalued right and i was being
devalued in a
very disciplined way right in terms of
it's not like it went 50
devaluation uh in a short period of time
but still being devalued
and so i think that people are waking up
to this idea that a traditional 60 40
type global portfolio
doesn't work anymore right 40 of it in
bonds
is just not going to get it done and so
when you
start to look at this people first look
at bitcoin via
two main ways in my opinion they look at
it one as a store value
should i actually go and put some of my
wealth there use it as a savings
technology
right we ask people in the traditional
world if you're a teacher
a fireman an accounting you know
mid-level manager
we say hey go do your job be best in
class as a fireman or as a teacher
and then oh by the way you'd be a
professional investor as well because if
you just put your dollars in your bank
account
you're literally going to have your
wealth devalued away over time so you
can't just save you have to invest
that is a really tall task for people
they have a hard enough time just doing
their job right
taking care of their family right now
they got to go be an investor
so i think savings technology for a
bitcoin standpoint is if you
buy satoshi's or bitcoin over time it
will
uh increase from a purchasing power
standpoint because there's a fixed
supply and demand continues to rise
but then you start to look at well what
other assets do people put in their
portfolios whether it's art
it's real estate it's precious metals or
something else
most of those assets are not because
people actually think that they're going
to go up in value over time
they're using a store of value right the
reason why somebody buys gold
is because it's a store of value right
historically that's a narrative driven
uh type asset though right we tell
people it's scarce we tell people that
it is a store of value
when you look at it though we don't know
how much gold exists in the world we
have a good
estimate right but we don't actually we
can't prove how much there is
we don't know how much is coming out of
the ground every day again great
fantastic estimate but we can't prove it
and we don't know what the total supply
and that's what you mean by narrative
driven we can't really prove it like
mathematically
we you i and everyone else in the world
has lived in a narrative driven world
for the last couple of decades right and
what the internet
and digital technologies have done is it
opened up the possibility
and the desire from people to have a
world now where i can validate things so
when i see
that headline i want to see you
say whatever happened to the news if
you're the subject of the news rather
than have somebody else tell me the
story
if i see that you say something is
scarce prove to me
that it is scarce and so i think that's
kind of a psychological shift the
younger generation is starting to
understand because
ultimately you and i probably grew up in
a world where parents could tell us the
story
and we just believed it you know dad or
mom says it it must be true
if my brother heard a story what does he
do he goes to google and he looks it up
randy comes back and usually tells my
parents how you got the story wrong
right
and so i think that that that
provability or that that validation
ends up becoming really really important
and so you know look at something like
gold i think that
people are drastically underestimating
the shift that's underway right now
gold is won down in value since april
or i'm sorry august of 2020. and so in a
time frame where central banks have had
historic quantitative easing literally
six trillion dollars in the united
states
the one asset that historically has been
the best store of value and has uh you
know in 2008 financial crisis
hit an all-time high based on the the
government response
has actually suffered uh for a main part
of this
financial crisis you then look at
central banks around the world who have
been
very large holders of gold for a long
time and net buyers on a monthly basis
for multiple months over the last six
months they've been net
sellers of gold and then you start to
look at
jewelry demand so the actual
non-monetary value of gold
and that demand for gold jewelry peaked
in 2013
and has continued to fall since and so
what you start to say to yourself is
take
just the asset of gold which about 10
trillion dollars market cap
and you say okay well if jewelry demand
continues to fall even if it's at a
slight rate but it continues to contract
you have central banks that now at some
times are net sellers and sometimes net
buyers right so okay again contraction
there
and then from the investment standpoint
the actual
price that the daily price of this
continues to fall which is
a signal that there's a contracting
demand from an investment perspective
that's 93 percent of all use of gold
only seven percent of it's used for
actual technology and metal conduction
and things like that
and so you have a 10 trillion dollar
asset that it appears and again maybe
data changes and i'll change my mind and
other people change their mind but it
appears
is on the decline and so if that happens
you're going to get the contraction of a
10 trillion dollar asset
where's all that value go and what
you're seeing is at the same time that
that asset is contracting
you're also seeing a massive influx
from not only retail investors not only
uh kind of
the wealthy and the elite but also from
financial institutions
corporations pension funds etc into this
kind of digital sound money so you're
saying that there's a kind of shift
from gold to bitcoin because they have a
lot of the same properties except
one is in the physical space the other
in the digital space so do you see like
central
banks uh quietly potentially switching
out
uh from sort of ghost gold to bitcoin
like naturally it's just doing is seeing
the
pattern that you're referring to now but
more drastically into the future where
there's a complete shift
if you line up the gold community and
the bitcoin community next to each other
they'll agree on all the problems that
they that they see in the world
right they'll actually agree on the
solution that sound money is the
solution
were they differentiate is the gold
communities
believes that it's the analog
application of sound money right the
physical gold
that is the solution the bitcoin
community believes the digital
application of sound money bitcoin
can you find sound money by the way
someone is just outside the system and
no one can create more of it so nobody
controls it
this scarcity is fundamental exactly why
scarcity important in money
i think scarcity just has this very high
correlation to value across all assets
not just money
right money happens to be the the unit
of account that we use in terms of
uh daily commerce um but whether it is
um you know as we're seeing how uh
sneakers are
you know what whatever it is uh scarcity
ultimately is that signal of value i
think and that's just
been the way that humans uh derive value
for literally you know thousands and
thousands of years yeah i gotta say
that's my view on life and love in
general is scarcity is what makes it
more valuable people talk about
immortality
i you know i would like to be immortal
but it does
it does seem that uh when you let go
of the fightiness of life i feel like
that meals and the experiences you have
get devalued significantly like the
longer you live
the less value there are in in infinity
if you live forever
i worry that all the meaning will will
dissipate and the same thing with love
a quick criticism of sort of dating
culture and all that kind of stuff
like i haven't uh had shocking
revelation that i've never been an
attended date or any of those things
i i believe that scarcity and dating and
interaction is like intensifies the
value of
when the interactions do happen so we'll
need like when love does happen
and so in that sense there's something
magical about scarcity in the more
subjective psychological social
world as well and perhaps money is just
another version of that right it's just
it's all about the stories and ideas we
tell ourselves
i think they're actually more
interconnected than you're giving it
credit for right which is
what is money money is time ultimately
right the the pursuit of
the acquisition of money right of
whether it's a currency or true money
is because that should give you more
time
and so one of my favorite movies ever is
uh and it's
funny because justin timberlake is in it
uh is this movie
i lose most people at that point in time
in time
and basically the premise of the movie
is that everyone has a clock that's
embedded into their arm
and so uh if you go to work you
basically
put your arm underneath when you leave
and there's time that's deposited into
your clock and if your clock ever hits
all zeros you're dead you die on the
spot
and so there's a number of scenes where
people are basically running
you know to get to you and i give you a
little bit more time so that you can get
to work on monday and then you
work to acquire time and so basically
time becomes this currency
but what becomes very fascinating about
it is there are sections in society
where literally there's physical places
if you only have let's say
72 hours or less you're allowed to go to
section 1.
section 5 though is because you have
years and years and years
on your clock and in this movie everyone
at the age of 25
freezes from a biological aging
standpoint
so everyone stays the same but you may
have lived for a thousand years
and so what becomes so fascinating about
it is that
rich people have time poor people do not
have time
and so in it justin timberlake the main
character at one point
uh essentially acquires a bunch of time
and he's able to go
to one of the higher levels and now he's
attending all these galas and you know
poker nights and all stuff
and one of the first things that he
learns is that in
the lower end of society everyone is
running everywhere
at all times in the movie because time
is so finite and it is so scarce
and so therefore why would i walk down
the street i must run down the street
in the highest level of society no one
runs anywhere and in fact if you run
you are seen as lower class yeah
because wealth is time and so that movie
is you know it's got a ton of kind of um
things that you can pull out of it but
to me
is the perfect epitome of money is time
and so when you start to think about the
acquisition
of money right it goes to this whole
idea of time billionaire and i know that
there's probably a lot of people have
heard about this already but
if you think of a million seconds it's
about
11 days a billion seconds is 31 years
and so if i said to somebody you have to
switch lives
with warren buffett would you do it
some people would say sure that'd be
their initial reaction i said but you
gotta have to be you know 92 years old
is the money worth the lack of time most
people would say no right there's this
guy graham duncan
who really articulated this well um and
ultimately what ends up happening is you
realize time is more valuable than the
money
but you you acquire the money to
gain more time and be the reason it's
valuable is because of the scarcity of
time
we currently have the the biology
the physics means that um
this is not just the narrative we tell
ourselves maybe this
i don't know but it it feels like
pretty sure we're mortal and in that
sense the scarcity there
gives value to time it's fascinating to
think about all the thought experiments
here
of if that could actually be on the
economy if you can actually convert time
in a frictionless way to money well and
if you start to pull on this a little
bit and say okay
a young person today let's say somebody
in their 20s has about 2 billion seconds
left in their life right kind of
60 years give or take based on life
expectancy
they usually until they start to
understand this
concept think of wealth
in dollar terms but dollars are being
devalued
and so you know a million dollars
doesn't get you what it used to get
right it's kind of a
an old adage and so what you're doing is
you're pursuing
something that ends up losing value and
so it's
the constant rat race it's how do i
constantly try to get more how do i get
more dollars how do i get more dollars
because even if i say to myself you know
i'm gonna retire when i get a hundred
thousand dollars
when i get the hundred thousand dollars
the hundred thousand dollars five years
from now doesn't buy me what i thought
it did so now i need
five hundred thousand or two hundred
thousand or a million or whatever the
number is
and so ultimately what ends up occurring
is that
the bitcoin community and many people in
kind of this idea of sound money
is you want to be able to acquire an
asset
that not only will hold the value right
the store of value over time
but it will actually appreciate over
time
and so when you look at something like
bitcoin against the dollar against other
types of assets
all of these assets are down compared to
bitcoin right now some of that's just
in the early days of kind of the pricing
of an asset you go from very small to
something much larger
but now what you start to look at is
well if you have a finite supply of
something
what ends up happening is people begin
to value it more
and so in a world where dollars are
infinite
and other fiat currencies are infinite
bitcoin becomes
very very interesting very special uh
and something that is very aspirational
and so i think that's where you're
starting to see people say wait a second
this is something where
that finite secure store of value
is essential to wealth generation and
preservation over a long period of time
and if sam harris is right that free
will is an illusion this is really
interesting to think about
maybe time is the kind of block chain
because you can't change anything and
then the
physical space time of the universe is a
ledger
so maybe uh it won't be bitcoin that
replaces gold
maybe it'll be time once we crack open
that
in fact the universe is fully
deterministic so maybe that's what like
eric weinstein is afraid of once you
figure out the theories
of everything of physics will be able to
then start
trading create a market out of like the
very fabric of reality
and that way break it well if you look
at
infinite inflationary type currencies
you can't do that right because it
constantly is losing value right
when you look at a finite asset again
that has the
provability of the actual finite element
to it
ultimately the wealth is
that marketplace yeah and so you know i
i always uh kind of try to highlight for
people the top 55
of americans understand something that
the bottom 45
don't they invest right the bottom 45
consume the top 55 percent invest and
that's why we have a wealth and equality
gap
and it continues to get wider and wider
and wider is because the people who are
holding the devaluing assets
and saving or watching their wealth be
devalued away
and there's arguments and controversy
over how fast that's happening but it's
happening
the people who are holding the assets
that have any level of scarcity right
real estate may not be finite
but it's scarce right art may not be
finite but it's scarce
gold may not be finite but it's scarce
those assets continue to
appreciate against the devaluing
currency and so when you then say no
i have complete finite supply
with provability and this transparency
around it where everyone knows
how much is there and what where it's
going now all of a sudden
you and i can transact back and forth
that value
and it is a representation of time
because what i can essentially do is if
i
gather or acquire more of that wealth i
then can apply
leverage to my life i can use machines
humans or some other resources
and basically now free up my time yeah
and it's not funny about the way you are
trading time maybe it's a little bit
indirect but
maybe not uh so just because i brought
up eric
and uh you're on twitter i'd love to
hear your opinions uh
i talk to him a lot he seems to have
stepped into the beautiful dance
of human communication and the social
dynamics that is the bitcoin
cryptocurrency community
do you have uh do you have thoughts on
uh
uh engaged theoretic concepts
conceptualization of the world there's
just eric in general
he's got a lot of love in his heart and
he's got a grace in the way he
communicates
but he's also uh loves to play with
ideas and seems to have touched a
sensitive point with the bitcoin
community is there anything you could
say
uh that's hopeful inspiring about that
whole dynamic that went down
i so i don't know all of the details um
but what i will say
is i've listened to a number of his
podcasts um and
him and there's a whole bunch of people
like him i basically put them in the
bucket of they're an independent thinker
who are courageous enough to speak their
truth whatever that may be they are
humble enough to revisit their ideas
and say i got this right i got this
wrong information changed i'll change my
mind
it's obviously a sign of intelligence to
be able to do that type of stuff
and i actually think that one of the
most scarce things in our society are
those independent thinkers who are able
to do all this
right speaking of scarcity yeah and so
to me
uh i put eric and a whole host of other
people kind of
if you look at like the intellectual
dark web is kind of a label that's uh
been used
they're actually some of the most
important people in our society
because they're the people who are
willing to stand up against the mass
kind of um thought process they're
willing to
talk about things that others may think
are taboo right they're willing to
change their mind which all of a sudden
has become a bad thing rather than a
good thing
and so when i see the exploration of
ideas in public
i actually think that those are the
people who are most open
to the kind of vehement blowback as well
right because that's part of what
they're doing is that they're eliciting
hey i'm going to throw an idea into the
arena if it doesn't get attacked they
actually may be more nervous
than if there is some level of you know
kind of war of attrition if you will
and so what i've seen with a number of
the people who have done this everyone
from
some of the best you know hedge fund
managers and kind of money managers in
the world
all the way to what i'll consider some
of the most uh intellectual people in
the world
is they play with these ideas and they
play with the ideas and they play with
them and they play with them
and they all arrive at the same
conclusion and sometimes it takes
a month sometimes it takes years but
they arrive at this bitcoin
thesis and what's so interesting about
it is it highlights something that
many people view as a bug but i think
people in the bitcoin community view as
a feature
which is that community and so what ends
up happening is
when you have something that is as
ambitious as
creating a global reserve currency
doesn't mean it needs to unseat any of
the existing ones but become the global
reserve currency of the internet right
this digital economy
you need shepherds of it and so just
like a technology company wants to find
those loyal fans that are willing to go
out and market and word of mouth
and and kind of not only promote it but
also
protect it this technology that is this
decentralized thing
which uses a financial incentive in
order to elicit the buy-in uh not from a
financial perspective but from a mental
energy standpoint has built one of the
most
rabid powerful and engaged communities
on the internet and what ends up
happening is
those people have thought more about
these ideas
and actually challenged those ideas more
than anyone else in the world
and so i've got a lot of folks who will
just say there's this guy marty bent who
we'll talk all the time about
the bitcoin critics haven't done their
homework in a lot of cases
so they show up and sometimes it's super
intellectual lazy arguments sometimes
it's actually very well thought out
arguments you know on the counter to the
bitcoin thesis
but ultimately what ends up happening is
you're talking to somebody who's
an expert i've been thinking about for
five seven eight ten years right they've
gone through every simulation you
possibly can
and they show up with data examples um
and responses now they're not always
right but they've just
done the work and so what i actually uh
like about folks like eric and others is
as they're kind of going through this
journey
they're incredibly smart right and they
provide uh or they um
apply a lot of intellectual rigor to
some of these arguments
and so what it does is what does it do
it's a marketplace it keeps people
honest
so i uh let me sort of make a few
comments it's kind of interesting uh so
you're exactly right
uh maybe the blowback is part of the
mechanism that actually develops these
ideas and so on
i do want to kind of speak to a little
bit of the toxicity that i've
experienced in the bitcoin community i
kind of see it
the bitcoin community i think he paints
a really nice picture which i kind of
see it as an immune system
that protects against sort of uh the
viruses
that are bad ideas that said the immune
system
can destroy a body right and
the thing you mentioned about eric and
maybe about myself
and in general just people exploring
ideas
is there is a dunning-kruger effect
which is when you first
start exploring ideas deeply you have
um overblown level of confidence about
like how much you understand
and that's actually the process about
learning then you realize you don't
understand much
what i've noticed with the bitcoin
community is uh
they're not as uh patient with the
the basics of the dunning-kruger effect
like if i step in
and make declarative statements about
bitcoin like i you know i read a long
time ago
uh the white paper like at the cursed
degree level i felt
uh that i understand the technology this
is basic intuitions
you know i didn't think about the social
dynamics i didn't think about any like
financial implications and
a lot of the deep actually the ongoing
innovations and all that kind of stuff
but i thought i understood that
technology and so i step in and make
declarative statements i think those are
the
the first time you say okay what's the
role of bitcoin in the world you start
thinking about it deeply
and then you make statements the
toxicity that you get in those first few
statements
is really off-putting to me i'm somebody
that tries to communicate love and
live that with everything i do and
there is a level of disrespect that i've
experienced
not directly just observing others
people have been mostly kind to me
and i appreciate that but if you're
going to criticize me
about my exploration of ideas in bitcoin
you have to also acknowledge that i'm a
human being they got like a phd
and stuff like i did some hard [ __ ] of
that it could be in farming or it could
be whatever
like i've lived life and i've really
thought deeply i really care
like i know a lot of [ __ ] and it's
possible
that i actually have a lot of ideas that
you can
learn from now if it's agriculture fine
or if it's
artificial intelligence fine like i know
what i'm talking about about certain
things
and i could be wrong about a lot of
things and there's like an exchange of
ideas that's
that makes the that mechanism that you
talked about
um more efficient sometimes when the
blowback is too strong
too early on the development of ideas is
just
inefficient and i'm not sure if if
there's a
you know the way it was explained to me
is that for so long
that community was like bombarded
with just like bad ideas like criticisms
there's just
overly sensitive now to like
to [ __ ] just they're like triggered
by statements like
they've heard it all before and they're
like oh there they go again with the
same old arguments
but that doesn't mean that um you know
you have to sort of i guess develop
patience and so on
especially when you feel like in my case
that the person is coming from a good
place right
i don't know if there's something you
could say yeah that's positive about the
future of this kind of overcoming this
toxicity
i think there's a couple of trends that
are all kind of coalescing here right
in these types of experiences so one is
uh when you look at a community
there's always um a spectrum right in
terms of
there's some people who over index on
kindness uh and stupidity
right and there's some people who over
index on intelligence and uh basically
just being an [ __ ]
right and then you get everyone in
between and so like uh
naturally as we know the extremist ends
of
uh any community end up being the
loudest usually right
the second thing is um
there is from the outsider view like in
at the beginning of the exploration of
ideas
uh it's very much a learning process
right it's it's
i don't know if i understand this or not
but piers ideas a b and c
from the internal perspective there's a
trillion dollars of value at stake and
we must protect it with our lives
yeah right the truth's probably
somewhere in between there
right again the world's not black and
white there's this kind of more gray
area that i think actually
um is where most people exist the other
thing that's at play here
is uh i think the bitcoin community
understands the internet and internet
culture
and uh narratives better than almost
anyone yes
and so you see this with kind of the uh
the just complete destruction
uh of narratives with memes and and um
just the the visceral reaction and the
use of things like
reddit and twitter and uh youtube
podcasts just
areas where um i think a lot about uh
if you are an upstart right and you are
going to go challenge
the most uh well-respected elite
kind of establishment institutions in
the world
if you walk in in a suit and tie and you
say
i'm here to debate you with ideas you're
going to get your clock cleaned
yeah right because they're going to trot
out their lawyers their regulators
they're lobbyists
right like all this stuff if you instead
say
i'm going to meme you to death on the
internet yeah and i'm going to control
the public narrative
you've shifted the the power the
asymmetry of power is more symmetrical
now it's the ultimate insurgency
right if you bring it back to the the
field yes
and so when you think about this you
have to lean into the advantage that you
have
yeah and so what ends up happening is
you and i
would absolutely lose it if we saw
jp morgan or goldman sachs or the
federal reserve
start tweeting memes yeah right it would
almost the the validation it would give
to the medium and the uh even playing
field that it would provide would
pull these establishments down to the
level of
what is this upstart but now what you're
starting to see
is that the bitcoin community even
though
there's some level of toxic toxicity at
times
even though there's this visceral
reaction sometimes
there's even what i would call bullying
or or
kind of outward projection of things
right even though it may be a small
percentage
it'll happen every once in a while what
they do understand though is that these
establishments
are made up of humans and what you can
actually do one of the best ways to pick
apart an institution
is to recruit from inside of them one by
one
yes and so what you're starting to see
now is
i mean i get the messages on twitter and
linkedin all the time
hey i'm a banker by trade i'm a
bitcoiner at heart
right and so what you're doing is you're
essentially infiltrating the
organizations
not in in physical uh you know uh
population
yeah but with the ideas and with the
philosophies
banker in the streets bitcoin are in the
sheets
i like it uh with that said uh in terms
of [ __ ] posting and memes
i gotta say um uh like
bring it on because i i believe
um in terms of asymmetry of power i
believe in
that love will save the world not memes
uh or at least
the good good vibe memes as opposed to
[ __ ] posting it's a it's an interesting
battleground though
it's an interesting battleground to
think about the other thing i would say
too is
um one of the elements uh that's always
kind of funny to me
is how much of the entertainment is love
right so when you start to think about
how many of the memes that are posted
for example
are for outsiders versus insiders yes
laser eyes
right which seems absolutely ridiculous
elementary and
and uh frankly uh beneath anyone in any
level of power or influence in the world
somehow has congressmen and senators who
have done it yeah
they're not trying to uh convince their
colleagues
in uh elected positions to become
bitcoiners yeah
they're speaking directly internally to
the bitcoin community yeah
there's some sense in which yes memes is
love
even if hearing bitcoin is love
they're trying to convert me uh the one
that you
the you uh you have to laugh at right
probably my favorite one out of all that
is i've seen on multiple occasions
uh you know mark cuban a couple of years
ago
kevin o'leary whoever you know wealthy
people billionaires et cetera
and you have people on anonymous
accounts who knows who they are
telling them have fun staying poor
and it's just you know it's just again
part of a community and i think it
it's uh it's a feature not a bug there's
bad aspects to it at times
but i do think it's a net positive it's
just like the immune system
it does a lot of crappy stuff but
overall it's a it's a major
net positive maybe this is a bit of a
personal question for me
just out of my own curiosity but i've uh
talked to ray daly a few times so ray
dalio i think
was one of those people that took the
that that journey
uh the the the bitcoin journey gift give
thoughts about him specifically
about that whole world and about the
journey maybe of others
that are going through the same process
because ray is
at least from my perspective i'm a bit
of an outsider he's
one of the most uh insightful
and deep thinkers about investment about
finance about
economics in general uh actually about
life
so it's interesting to see him go on
that journey
do you have something in common about
rey or just those kinds of people in
general
so if we look at um what i'll just
consider the legends of wall street in
general yeah right
um there's no denying that they're
incredibly intelligent uh there's no
denying that
actually especially in the hedge fund
world they're some of the most
open-minded
people uh in terms of they're willing to
change their mind when they get new
information
there's no doubt that they are
historians in the sense of having
studied financial markets and cycles
over time
and also uh one of the things that i
really respect about all those guys is
almost all of them are willing to put
ideas out uh via various writings that
they do
uh and accept the public criticism right
whether it's howard marx ray or others
uh they will put this stuff out in
public and uh sure there's a lot of
people who
um are supportive and kind of are part
of a fan base
if you will but there's a lot of people
who also think that sometimes they say
stupid things
and so putting that out takes kind of
courage right um
i think ray's actually the most
fascinating though out of all of these
kind of legends of wall street in that
um he understands debt cycles he
understands currencies
he for a while now has been all over
and famously said you know cash's trash
uh
investable assets right he just he kind
of like just knew all of it
and for a long time bitcoiners have said
ray you understand the bitcoin argument
you're just missing the last part which
is
bitcoin's the solution right and so he
was gold and some other ideas but
i think that he's a perfect example of
when you are part of
uh the establishment people view you in
a very static way as
uh the leader of a part of establishment
but whether it's bill gates ray dalio or
somebody else
each one of these people were innovators
and challengers to a system they were
upstarts at one point
and so it's kind of this idea that like
if you live long enough you eventually
become the man
right and so you know gates is a good
example right
warren buffett is a good example ray
dalio's a good example etc and so
uh you have to give credit i think to
dalio in the sense of
he kept an open mind about all of this
and
more so than many of his peers has
continued to do the work and come around
to this idea
and now i don't want to know if i want
to say that he's a bitcoin proponent
as much as he believes it is one of you
know a portion of assets that can be a
solution
and so to me when you start to convince
those types of people when it's you know
paul tudor jones or stanley
druckenmiller
ray dalio howard mark's now even writing
about it saying hey
you know i was anti-bitcoin i didn't put
a ton of intellectual
rigor into it but thank god my son
bought a bunch of our family
right and uh and kind of we've had
exposure to it
i think what it does is more than
anything it's not going to convince
somebody to go and
um you know take it seriously or
go ahead and make an allocation it
reduces career risk and so if all of a
sudden when paul tudor jones and stanley
dracula come out and say hey i own
bitcoin and here's why
every other investor on wall street now
can say to an investment committee
well it's good enough for paul tudor
jones it's good enough for stanley
druckenmiller
and so i think that it's very
interesting because rey doesn't just
represent
wall street i think ray in some weird
way represents this like
macro economic investor and so some of
those are in hedge funds and some of
those
people would be like cios at
organizations some of them would be at
corporations and some of them are just
kind of retail investors
and so you can see this kind of
inflection point
throughout the adoption of bitcoin right
there was infrastructure that got built
okay that kind of led to more adoption
there was
certain individuals right usually they
were kind of technology oriented
entrepreneurial billionaires they would
buy it and come out and say it okay that
led to inflection points
uh you started to have some of these
kind of wall street legends
come out started financial institutions
started
now you're seeing corporations start to
do it right eventually there's gonna be
a central bank that does it
and so you kind of walk through that
line and what you understand it's like
it's the same thing every time it's just
somebody new
right that that path right that
bitcoiner's journey if you will
and i think that that is almost the
beauty
of it is uh if you short circuit the
journey
it's almost like somebody doesn't
appreciate it right if you take let's
say somebody who's a young kid and you
just give them a bunch of money and they
didn't have to work hard for it
they don't really appreciate it and uh
ray
ray actually has the book principles
right and he talks about the hero's
journey so
he's like living in some sense in terms
of
you know thinking about digital currency
in general like
digital finance it's one of the big
transitions
transformations of our world
in some sense it's not just about money
or you could argue that money is
everything i mean it's like
money isn't just the the narrow
definition of money money is really
everything
and so we're you could argue that sort
of uh cryptocurrency
is like the base layer of this
transformation to the digital space and
everything else will just be
built on top of it i use a different
word um
that i think is kind of closer to your
world which is
it's ultimately automation and what i
mean by that
is uh you know before 1970 or 1980 all
the assets were analog
and so when you have analog assets
physical stock certificates physical
bonds right physical
deed to a home you have to physically
exchange them
yeah when we wanted to increase
transactions and increase kind of global
finance and access
we took those physical assets and we
created electronic qsip assets so now we
have in centralized databases kind of a
file
represents the asset that's sitting
somewhere in custody
and you and i can transact them a little
bit easier but still centralized there's
still some bureaucracy
and you know maybe it takes two days to
transact rather than
actually mailing it across the other
world
now what we're seeing is a transition
from those electronic q-sips to these
digital assets
and so if you look at again just let's
say money uh or currency
every currency in the world is going to
be digital you're gonna have a digital
dollar
a digital euro yen rmb you're gonna have
decentralized uh kind of open source uh
money like bitcoin you're also gonna
have private currencies
like facebook's attempt at dm uh and
there will be others that will try to do
this
and so when you get everything digital
right and i think that's the kind of
first step everyone focuses on
the competition at the technology layer
essentially goes away
you get some level of feature parity and
sure there's bells and whistles on each
kind of implementation of a digital
currency
but at the end of the day the technology
is relatively the same and ultimately
what it will do is it will facilitate
the adoption of
digital wallets so you have to have a
digital wallet regardless of what
digital currency you have same with me
same with everybody else in the world
but what it does do is when you
kind of uh push away and reduce the
friction of competition at the
technology layer it moves the
competition to the monetary policy layer
and so when you get to that layer now
often it becomes interesting because all
of the currencies are the same
except for this one right now and maybe
there will be others in the future
uh but but for sure bitcoin today and
people may try to replicate in a private
manner or something but bitcoin is kind
of the the only
finite scarce digital cell money and so
when you then have that pretty big
difference in that competition at the
monetary policy layer
it's actually not going to matter where
you get paid
right and what i mean by that is like
you and i both live in a single currency
environment i get paid in dollars
i historically have saved in dollars all
of the assets in my life
are denominated in dollars and i owe
my debts in dollars whether it's taxes
or in the private market
and i don't have to worry about foreign
currencies i don't exchange anything the
only time i would ever think about in
other currencies if i'm going to another
country
in their single currency environment and
in order to
change or exchange my currency i go to
the bank
or i go get ripped off at the airport
right like those are my two options so
it's high friction
to change between currencies when the
competition
of technology is kind of um innovated
away
now i can get paid in dollars these
digital dollars and with a click of a
button switching to any other currency
in the world
and so what ultimately happens is value
and liquidity is going to coalesce
around
the best monetary policy and so you get
in this very weird world where even if
the united states says hey you're gonna
get paid in dollars you have to pay your
taxes in dollars
you're gonna start to see people operate
in a multi-currency environment where
they say okay i got paid my digital
dollar click a button i save in bitcoin
it stays there protects or grows my
purchasing power oh i need to pay my
taxes let me switch back into dollars
with click of a button and pay
when you go to a multi-currency world
it's not just about currency
it's now multi-asset world because not
only is the
currency digitized but that same
technology is used to digitize
stocks bonds and commodities as well and
so today we live in a very fragmented
financial world where basically i have a
brokerage account
i have a bank account i may have an
alternative asset account etc
when i can put all those assets in a
single digital wallet
and i can then go from asset to asset
without having to go back to a single
unit of account
like frictionless uh going from acid to
asset yeah
so now what you end up doing is you
start to open up the possibility for
machine-to-machine transactions
so today if you and i write software
code for two machines to transact with
each other
yeah they can't transact physical
currency and in many cases they can't
actually transact the electronic q-sip
currencies or assets either
because there's too long of a settlement
time so you can't get true automation
right so the whole idea of like the
car's going to drive over a strip in the
road it's going to pay the toll
right well that can't happen right now
because literally the transaction won't
go through right
and so i always joke that like in an
automated world
it's like a cd-rom but we're trying to
take cassette tape player assets and put
it in the cd-rom
it's just incompatible technology
references nobody understands at this
point
oh by the way you need to update your
references i probably do it's like
taking a cd-rom trying to put an mp3
player
into uh streaming but but i think that
the reason why that becomes really
interesting is when you start to
create these digital assets now you open
up the world of possibilities
so when new technology is created you
can do two things you can either create
new things the world's never seen before
or you can use it to improve the old
world
most people because it's the easiest
thing to think about
want to improve the old world so an
equivalent of this would be
when the internet came along a media
company that had newspapers
would say hey we should take a pdf of
the newspaper and we should put it on a
website
and now anyone in the world can go to
this website they can read the newspaper
today
that was valuable but it missed out on
the ability to change headlines
to test to put multimedia to distribute
it differently to
you know do all kinds of things that
today we understand the internet really
empowered
and so what i think we're about to watch
happen is we're going to digitize the
assets
we're going to put them all into these
digital wallets
you're going to get automated
technologies where machines cannot
transact with each other
and we're going to do simple things like
why do we pay
people once every two weeks why don't we
just pay them at the end of every day
or why don't i literally stream payments
to you yeah on an hour-by-hour basis
based on the work you do
it would solve incredible economic
issues in our country and in countries
around the world
but historically businesses can't do
this because the technology problem
they can't keep track of it all how do
they pay everyone every day how do they
pay everyone every hour like
you just can't do it yeah it's funny the
the the vision of the future you're
painting
it's kind of an exciting one and it
almost makes me sad
looking into the future when we'll look
back at this time it's like
is how incredibly inefficient
our financial transactions were like the
transaction of value of any kind
like how like what to pay each other
like there has
like processes there's like payroll and
all this kind of
just the the entirety of the
transactions is just
like painful almost all transactions are
painful
and even and the companies that innovate
to make
the transactions a little bit more
frictionless like amazon with the
one-click purchase button
like went out huge but even that's
really painful
so it's actually really interesting
especially then you start to move that
into the space of data
there's a lot of people thinking about
privacy and data and like can we put
can we uh like convert data into
like money it's just so that you can pay
for how much you reveal to the companies
about your own private data that can
then be
used to assign value to you so you can
use a service for free
if you hand over the data but there's
like explicit transaction going on
so you can empower all those kinds of
things
that uh will just like fundamentally
change our world that's that's really
really really exciting
one of one of the most interesting
things to me um is i invested in a
company called bridget
what they told me was they said eight
billion dollars
was paid to the top four banks last year
on overdraft fees okay so literally they
took eight billion dollars from people
who didn't have money in their bank
account
right and so when you dig into why is
that a lot of times it's not that
the people don't have the money it's
actually a mismatch of
the payments yeah so what ends up
happening is you get paid on the first
and the 15th
but on the 12th your netflix bill hits
on the 13th you went grocery shopping
and on the 14th your car payments
hit you overdraft and then on the 15th
you actually get the check and then
you're able to pay not only the
overdraft but for the
expenses that you have and so something
as simple as just getting paid at the
end of every day
immediately would eliminate you know
some big percentage of those eight
billion dollars of value that flows to
large institutions on overdraft fees
yeah and also i mean this whole process
with overdraft fees
and just many of the financial
transactions we have to live through
today
forces many of us to be like accountants
like to understand uh the different
mechanism of financial like
movement of money as opposed to you
which is what we want to do as human
beings
operating in higher layers of like
providing services for others
of like following your passions and like
working for
others like doing cool [ __ ] or or
you know basically providing value
exchanging value in the world and not
thinking about the money
the money takes care of itself and then
you see the results of it so you're
you're able to think in terms of
money but not have to know
how the like the accounting works
automation
simply frees humans up to do more
creative work yeah
right yeah like that like that's it yeah
and which is why they use the term
which is why you use the term automation
which i think is kind of brilliant
uh reframing of all this yeah because
ultimately
digital technologies are merely the
conduit to usher us into that world
yeah and i think the most fascinating
part
of this entire industry is
people who are trying to figure out now
that we're going to have these digital
technologies
how do we usher in that automated world
faster
and so there's people who are building
all kinds of incredible things right
there's literally
um some technologies where you can
stream uh for paying for consumption of
content
yeah right there's i saw somebody
recently who they basically said hey
i have created something but it's not
gonna be released
until everyone and almost like a
gofundme type
situation pays for in combination then
it gets unlocked
and so when you start to think about
this it's not only innovation on the
technology front it's innovation around
the way that we form capital it's the
way that we
organize resources it's the way that we
build companies it's the business models
right it's the application of those
technologies
all that stuff starts to change and go
back to
20 uh 2007 is when the iphone came out
uber wasn't possible right he's going
online like all these companies that
weren't possible before
when the digital technologies are kind
of adopted on a global scale
i think that we all myself included
drastically underestimate how
fast and how big innovation can be uh
because it's just hard
right like like we like to think
linearly and that's not how the world
works
yeah i i do find it kind of interesting
uh
it is nft based but uh i i don't think
it has to be
this uh this idea of i think
big clout it's called or whatever uh the
idea of sort of investing in individuals
it makes me immediately think about
investing in
ideas so even just the words you speak
having value and sort of
if you have a frictionless like
automated
financial system then you could do a
bunch of interesting things about
what it means to add value to the world
i mean
i don't know if bit cloud is currently
an efficient representation of that
but i am truly happy
that however that thing works
i'm just one notch above vladimir putin
which is one of the that's like one of
the bucket list items for me
to have a list where i'm one notch above
putin
well what i think you're talking about
here is important because there's
uh historical examples you could invest
in
a patent in some situations you could
invest in
an organization that has an idea right
so these are
super inefficient given kind of the
vision that you're painting in terms of
like investing directly in an idea in a
super efficient automated fashion
but that's how the technology evolution
works right
is it's really hard to do it first and
then slowly kind of becomes easier and
easier as technology
uh is more prevalent the other thing
that i think is interesting is this
whole idea of investing in people
if you really think about the
origination of that is i would hire
somebody
right i pay you money and then you're
going to create production
but i take the lion's share and you
don't now there's things like
these isas these income sharing
agreements where basically i will
educate you on something train you on
something i'll put up capital
right and then over time you'll pay me
back plus profits
as some version eventually i don't know
what it looks like
but being able to get upside in
somebody's success
for having risk capital early on doesn't
seem that far off
seen in professional sports you see it
in you know a lot of these things and so
i just think that a lot of um the focus
right now
is on the technology but ultimately
these are
ideas that are very old and have had
lots of success and traction and we're
just merely standing in the way of the
evolution of these ideas with new
technology and so
uh it's easy to get caught up in the
technology but when you really zoom out
and look at it from the
ideological standpoint and kind of the
the progress of humanity
it's a foregone conclusion this stuff's
going to happen it's just how
i think the world is waiting and some of
us are trying to create
that future world which is like what are
the applications of this technology that
will transform the world
and then you know i hate the term but
killer apps like
cool ideas that are implemented
effectively at scale to transform the
world there's been
there's been a lot of different ideas
popping up
like the there's a lot of ideas about
social networks that are built on top of
the technology and all that kind of
stuff
so but let me actually uh drag us back
down to something basic
if a person wanted to buy bitcoin
store bitcoin how do they actually do it
yeah
so there's a couple of different ways to
kind of uh acquire bitcoin
and in every way you've got to exchange
some form of value
for bitcoin right which is part of why
it has values because you're giving up
value
so um in one way is to exchange
uh energy and computational power
for bitcoin so you can mine it you can
literally take
uh computer power that you have you can
rent it to the network
uh and run that software and then it
will pay you
a portion of the kind of daily revenue
uh off that system
you can acquire bitcoin in exchange for
your power uh and your computational
um kind of contribution and that's the
fundamental principle behind bitcoin
is the proof of work so i got a hundred
bucks
uh like i use cash app uh
you know they uh there's coinbase
there's all these exchanges
like how do i convert my hundred dollars
to uh to bitcoin is there something
disclaimer this is not financial advice
and this is just us
uh talking is just your opinions just do
not use this to invest
um or take us financial expertise
that said uh like uh is there something
you recommend that's an easy entry point
for somebody
that's like hmm i wonder if i can
convert this hundred dollars into
whatever amount of bitcoin what do you
recommend what are the options
so there's a lot of options uh i'm
heavily biased i went out and i
scoured the market looked at all of them
i've invested a lot of money in a
company called block fi
that basically um basically has
financial products for crypto investors
so you can go you can take
dollars or other currency you have you
can convert it through an exchange
uh you can leave it on these interest
bearing accounts you can earn interest
just like you would earn in a
traditional account but
higher levels of interest because it's
this new thing or you can withdraw
it and you can put it into cold storage
on a hardware device you can leave it in
a software wall there's kind of all
these storage options
uh so block file is you know kind of the
one that i'm biased towards because
so block files or sorry to interrupt uh
so the block fi
is is uh bitcoin only or is it an
exchange with the
other crypto it's got a bunch of
different ones yeah they basically are
agnostic
to what it is um but they provide uh
kind of financial
you know products to crypto investors
okay so you mentioned a few
interesting ideas that'd be nice for
people who would not be familiar
with it uh cold storage hot storage uh
what does that mean so like
i go to a website and i convert dollars
to bitcoin
that's the kind of storage that's like
online banking
right what else is there
so there's a couple of different things
that you can do right and let's use the
legacy system as kind of an example so
if i want to um get currency
and i put in my bank account it sits
there i have to trust that the bank
doesn't go under nobody steals it all
this kind of stuff there's insurance for
it right
there's all these kind of benefits in
the legacy system to make sure that as
long as i don't have
millions and millions of dollars there
i'm going to be protected pretty much if
anything happens
through fdic insurance if
i want to do that i'm taking that
counterparty risk though
so it's mitigated but there's still
counterparty risk i'm counting on that
bank
but it is easier to move it around right
if all of a sudden you call me up and
say hey send me some money i can press a
couple buttons on my computer
and it'll send it to you if i want
deeper level of security
i can go and i can get the physical
dollars and i can go and i can
you know put under my mattress right and
i can say you know what
it's not gonna be as easy to send it to
you immediately but if i really want to
i can go
underneath my mattress pretty quickly i
can grab it i can get it back to the
bank and then i can send you the money
the third thing i could do is i could
basically take those physical dollars
out of the bank and i could go and i
could go put it literally
uh you know in a vault somewhere that i
don't have control over that's behind 10
passwords
uh and biometric scanning and like it's
really difficult to even get to it yeah
right
so if you almost look at it as like
there's three stages of security that
you could have in the traditional world
the same thing is true in bitcoin so you
could buy bitcoin on any exchange you
could do it on wi-fi but you also can do
it on places like coinbase gemini
kraken etc also cash app
cash app you can do that i think i i
think there's
still sponsoring this podcast i'm not
biased at all
so once you get bitcoin on any of these
uh venues
uh you can leave it there on that venue
now the trade-off is you're taking
counterparty risk so somebody else
is responsible for the security and the
protection of it uh
in many cases big well-known companies
who have billions and billions of
dollars of assets
they have higher levels of security
that's why they're well known that's why
people trust them whatever but you are
taking counterparty risk
it is easier to quickly send to somebody
so this so the trade-off of like ease of
use
uh but counterparty risk is big and in
the bitcoin community specifically
this is a huge thing of uh they really
really have a cape for
not leaving the bitcoin there right for
the obvious counter priority
the second thing you can do is you can
basically get it off of an exchange and
you can put it in
some level of kind of what i'll call a
second layer of storage that second
layer storage could be
a hardware device that you can quickly
just you know grab off your desk and
plug into your computer and immediately
use that's what they call like a
hardware
hardware wallet yep or you can have some
sort of software wallet right where it's
not on
an exchange but there is some level of
uh in between between the hardware
wallet and the exchange in this software
wallet but the software wallet is
connected to the internet yeah
and so um if you kind of think of it as
like the exchange
software wallet hardware wallet and then
there's something called deep storage
right or cold storage um and this is you
know literally there was a
a company uh called zappo that uh would
put things in deep cold storage
and it was literally buried in a
mountain
right so like the odds that somebody's
physically gonna go there there's armed
guards there's you know kind of all this
type of stuff
but again you're taking some level of
counterparty risk because they have your
bitcoin
and so the saying or the phrase uh is
not your keys not your coins uh whereas
my buddy isaiah jackson came up with
these said uh uh
not your keys not your cheese right in
terms of uh
uh sovereignty is important right and
ultimately this goes back to
kind of the beginning of a conversation
around bitcoin's ethos
sovereignty right giving the power back
to people you don't have to rely on
uh this infrastructure in order to be
able to participate in this monetary
uh kind of economy which you are now
able to do is you're able to
use digital sound money you're able to
keep control of it
you and you alone are responsible for it
so the idea of personal responsibility
um and then also you and you alone make
the decisions as to
whether you hold on to it or you use it
without censorship right no one can tell
you what you can do with it or can't do
with it and so
the purchase and the storage what i find
is uh depending on who you are there's
varying uh degrees of kind of concern
or decisions that get made there a lot
of it comes down to personal preference
the bitcoin community though absolutely
will over optimize for
uh sovereignty and uh kind of hardware
or cold storage
i wonder if you can sort of comment on
that because you you have uh
uh sort of uh cash app and block fi and
coinbase
like you can store it that you can
purchase and trade it there and store it
there and so on but ultimately they're
saying
you want to you know keep some of it
there but you want to move it to the
hardware
wallet and the cold storage of the
hardware wallet
is like you can disconnect it from the
computer because ultimately stuff that's
connected to the internet
can be compromised can be controlled by
governments and other parties and so on
what are your thoughts about sort of
practically speaking for
maybe like a regular citizen what's
what should be the role of the hardware
wallet in their lives
yeah so at the highest level i just
think that like learning about it is
important
right so even if you only have five
dollars equivalent of bitcoin
going and understanding here's how it
works here's why it's important
here's how i would actually withdraw
from an exchange under the hardware wall
like that alone
just as an intellectual exercise is a
worthwhile pursuit i think people should
go do that
and actually go through the process of
the steps so you feel like you can
you can do it yeah yeah it's kind of
like if i said to you you know hey we're
gonna go buy an asset
and you never went and you looked at it
you never went and uh you know made a
decision like
sure maybe i did it or i didn't do it
but like you didn't actually experience
it right and so i think that that's the
important part
the second thing is uh each person is
different from a
how they view this asset so there are
some people who are speculating right
there's three use cases for bitcoin
there's store value medium of exchange
and speculation
and the people who are speculating they
can't put it in deep cold storage
because they need to be able to trade it
right so what ends up happening is they
fall in the bucket of like high risk
high reward
they're trying to trade they're trying
to do all these things and sure maybe
there are profits that they can generate
if they're good at it
but also they're introducing a lot of
risk and so that person is very
different than the person who says hey
you know i bought one bitcoin and i'm
gonna
save it for my child right and i'm gonna
give it to them on their 18th birthday
yeah and so when you start to look at
this what you end up saying is
what are you actually purchasing this
for kind of like why are you doing it
and then what's your time horizon and
what ends up happening is
more and more people in the bitcoin
community have longer time horizons one
of the advantages to
uh this community right if you look at
the on-chain metrics 60
of bitcoin haven't moved uh from the
digital wallet in which they sit
in the last 12 months so even though
it's appreciated hundreds of percent
on the upside there's been lots of
volatility a 50 drop in a single day
in terms of the us dollar price still
doesn't move and so these are
kind of the long-term holders right
these are the the iron fists or
as recently as it's become popular the
diamond hands right
hands they're just they're not going
anywhere and so i think that
those people are much more likely to not
have their bitcoin
on exchanges or in software walls
they've got it in some sort of like
highly secure
environment uh and what and one in which
they have
deep sovereignty or kind of prevalent
sovereignty
and the reason for that is because they
have that long time horizon they don't
want to be
um kind of convicted around bitcoin
sound money macro environment all stuff
and then they make a mistake because
they trusted
you know abcd company uh and that
counterparty risk because it ends up
actually being
you know fatal or or detrimental so
again this is
not financial advice disclaimer but
uh let me ask so you in terms of
investment advice on bitcoin
so you see bitcoins potentially not just
the thing that you sp
speculate over like buy and sell buy and
sell buy and sell
but it's something that you can just buy
only and i believe
i've heard that you own uh quite a large
percentage of you
of your wealth in in bitcoin and you're
basically
buying only yeah and storing long term
so that's something that's a legitimate
way to approach bitcoin in your
recommendation
go to other cultures so if we remove
ourselves from the western world culture
of uh investing in gamification of
financial markets and the
financialization of everything
let's say we go to uh the culture of
india
for hundreds if not thousands of years
families basically
saved their wealth in gold and in
jewelry
and in these hard assets with the
expectation
to pass it on to the next generation and
so
it would be blasphemous to sell the
family's gold
in that culture right you know your
great grandfather gave it to your
grandfather your grandfather gave it to
your father your father gave it to you
right and so in that culture
the long-term kind of uh holding
is the default i think that what bitcoin
has presented again is a digital
application
of the exact same thing which is that
while everything else in the world is
being devalued that is denominated in a
uh a currency that is being inflated
away
whether it's quickly or not this finite
supply this scarce asset ends up
accruing more and more value over time
right
and so um i think that for me personally
um i've got you know over 95 of my net
worth that's in this
90 over 95 percent of your net worth
there's two important caveats to this
one
is i didn't you know buy some bitcoin in
2011 or 12
right and then also it appreciated a
bunch and it grew into that but
from a cost basis perspective you know i
put 100 and now it's
a ton of money instead what i did was i
basically in 2018
um saw bitcoin from a us dollar price
standpoint was falling and falling and
falling
and in december of 2018 it said take
about 50 of my net worth
and convert it from dollar denominated
assets into bitcoin so it was a very
kind of intentional decision with a very
specific view on the world as to like
why i was doing it
i then essentially just let it sit there
grow whatever
until uh the spring of 2020.
and when i saw the government step in
and start to say hey we're going to
really be aggressive in terms of
interest rate manipulation and
quantitative easing
i then decided to go ahead and take
basically the remainder
and start to convert it as well so i
became very aggressive in doing that
and so the way that i look at it is
that's actually my savings
right and so in some weird way if i said
to you know what's the dollar worth
you'd say well
a one dollar bill's worth one dollar
right bitcoin to me i denominate my
wealth in bitcoin
so i think of one bitcoin is worth one
bitcoin not one bitcoin is worth sixty
thousand or fifty five thousand or
seventy thousand right i denominate
everything in bitcoin when i make a
purchase
in my head i'm calculating how much
bitcoin am i spending right now
right well guess what happens when you
have a devaluing currency as the
denominator
doesn't matter right like you're
financially incentivized to spend or
invest right to consume
uh when you have an appreciating
currency
all of a sudden you become much less
consumptive
yeah because you're actually trading off
future purchasing power yeah for the
consumption today
it's fascinating to think that if if uh
when you move about this world you think
in bitcoin
you behave differently is if you think
in dollars
that's really fascinating people but but
here's the thing is
the last 50 years or so is actually the
outlier in history
most people used to think this way yeah
it's only when
a fiat currency got introduced that
one argument the positive argument or
perspective is there was an explosion in
growth
but really it's because there was a
financial incentive to consume yeah
right and there's nobody better in the
world than the united states
at consuming and we consume anything and
everything
and if you want to see a great example
look at how big the coca-colas are at
mcdonald's
right you know you go to other places
they don't serve them that big
and so the other example or the negative
argument
is we have to consume
because if not you end up being the
bottom 45 percent of americans that held
no investable assets
and actually are just having their
wealth devalued away so holding the
dollars
end up being a very bad economic
decision
and so when you then switch to this
sound money
you say wait a second why would i if
today i can trade one bitcoin
you know back in october of last year
one bitcoin for 10
000 us dollars why would i spend that if
at some point in the future whether it's
a month from now or 10 years from now
i could trade it for something much more
than that
you just become much more of a um
uh anti-consumer and much more of a
long-term
thinker yeah from the individual
perspective that's pretty powerful i
wonder
i mean i think that's an interesting
debate what's better for the long-term
economy no
uh better for the growth of the
civilization
because capitalism is fascinating uh
it seems to it seems to work pretty well
there's this kind of like eric weinstein
says that one of the problems is
for the past several decades this whole
economy
society is built on the idea that we
have to keep growing
like it depends on that idea and it's a
good question whether that's going to
result in huge problems or if like a
college student on a deadline
the the dependence on growth will mean
that we'll have to grow
like the fear of death will force us to
grow
but i think there's a false equivalency
between um
we're dependent on growth and then if
the world was denominated and sound
money
we don't grow what i think ends up
happening is
we remove a lot of the society's
[ __ ] yeah
because right now when the money is free
or
the currency is free you can come up
with all kinds of crazy stuff and people
will give it to you
right when all of a sudden it's really
really valued by the population the
decisions are better
yeah you have to provide real value in
the goods and services you provide
to get them to give it to you there's
less room for corruption less room for
manipulation that's
and like that's not actually productive
yeah uh
definitely so you said you moved a lot
of
your investment into bitcoin and is
there
uh when you look so you're a special
human being in many ways uh so you're
like a strategic thinker but you're also
like a deep thinker about this whole
thing
but when you look at a regular club like
me uh in terms of just
investing and moving into uh thinking
about cryptocurrency
is there a strategy that you recommend
what are the different options about
investing
into bitcoin yeah so i think that
there's just uh kind of
timeless advice when it comes to uh
investing or acquiring an asset in
general
uh dollar cost averaging is usually the
the best way to think about it and what
i mean by that
is um most people don't just have a pile
of
uh currency sitting there right it's not
like they have a million dollars sitting
in their banks like what do i do with it
uh that situation aside what happens is
they
trade their hours and their effort for
currency and so as they get paid every
two weeks let's say
um the best way to acquire bitcoin
without having to worry about timing
markets and being a professional trader
is to simply take whatever the
percentage is that you want and to
buy bitcoin when you get your paycheck
so if you get paid on the first and 15th
of every month
on that day you should go take you know
let's say it's three percent of your
paycheck
take three percent go buy bitcoin don't
worry about what the price is just do
that over time
and the reason why that's important is
um if in december of 2017 when bitcoin
was at 20 000
it was the height of kind of this last
big upwards movement
you had taken all of your money and you
had put it into bitcoin
you would have had to wait almost three
years just to get back to quote-unquote
break even in us dollar terms if at the
same time
you had simply bought then and over the
next three years bought every two weeks
you would have been up hundreds of
percent three years later
because what ended up happening was you
bought a bunch of bitcoin when it was at
12 10 9 8 3 4
5 5 5 you know all the way back up on
the other side
and so dollar cost averaging is one of
these weird things that uh it almost
sounds too easy
but what we find is in america we have a
lack of financial education
and so rather than try to be smarter
than markets what most people are better
off doing is just saying hey
set your what's called an asset
allocation plan i want
30 in stocks i want 10 real estate i
want this this whatever
and every time you get your paycheck
just think of it as a savings account
right just put it in based on those
percentages and don't think about it
and over a long enough period of time
what we find is
almost anyone in the united states right
there's exceptions but almost anyone in
the united states
can become a millionaire in their
lifetime if they follow these plans and
have that long-term view and they allow
compounding to work for them
and so don't look at the price of
bitcoin and all that kind of stuff just
pick a
specific time specific day that you just
buy
and you just keep buying that's probably
good investment advice across any kind
of assets
it's like if you don't believe in
bitcoin and you just want to let's say
you just want to do the s p 500
yeah you shouldn't try to time the
market of the s p 500 either right you
should just
every two weeks you should just buy
something over a 20-year period
you're gonna end up buying it at all
kinds of different prices but you're
gonna get kind of a blended average
and the more important thing is the
compounding and the time in the market
then did you buy it at you know two
percent higher or lower than where you
bought it doesn't
really matter and buying often makes you
i guess uh resistant robust
to the uh to the volatility of the
market or the volatility the bitcoin
price and so on
that said uh you know bitcoin price
is volatile and
you know again the argument i've heard
is like everything that's going to be
a lot more valuable in the future
like if you look at the history like
companies like apple
like tesla's now i mean but
you know let's look at companies that
have now stabilized right
uh apple is a good example it's like
volatile in the beginning
and so the argument for bitcoin is like
yeah this is the early stages because
it's going to be a lot more valuable
and right now it's volatile and this is
why you have to have these kinds of
strategies to write out the volatility
of course everything that goes to zero
is also volatile
like the early days are volatile uh
do you see like this volatility is like
a feature or a bug
or is this just like a way of life so
amazon is the one that i know the
numbers on in terms of early volatility
uh every year since they've gone it has
gone public it's had a double-digit
drawdown in that year uh the average
is over 30 percent and one time it drew
down over 95 percent
sounds a lot like bitcoin right like oh
wow this is crazy
but it's one of the best performing
stocks in the last 20 years if not the
best performing stock
and so volatility is not positive or
negative
it's positive or negative compared to
the position you're in
so if you're long and it's volatile to
the upside
it's positive if you're long holding
something and it's volatile to the
downside
you see it as a negative it's all about
perspective with that said
um another way that i look at this is
every asset priced in bitcoin
is down significantly so over the last
one three five years the dollar
priced in bitcoin has crashed 99
if you denominate stocks it's down like
85 if you dominate gold if you
denominate bonds if you just go down the
line real estate et cetera it's all down
massively against bitcoin now you could
argue that that's because
bitcoin is appreciating in u.s dollar
terms or you could actually
argue that the world is repricing this
asset it's doing price discovery on this
asset
and it's essentially comparing it's
saying hey bitcoin versus this stock or
bitcoin versus this ounce of gold or
bitcoin
verse you know this dollar which is more
valuable and it continues to move up in
the rankings in terms of the value that
the world
ascribes to this some that's based on
lindy effect just the longer it persists
the more likely it is to survive
some of that's based on like the
underlying fundamentals of how much
computing power
the usage transaction volume things like
that but some of it also
is that as more and more people wake up
to the fact that it's a finite supply
asset that has a place in the world
and demand increases people just
naturally compete and
ascribe more value to it and so the
volatility
i think all comes back to like what do
you price
your life in for the majority of people
that's dollars so you look at the us
dollar price you get all this volatility
the beauty of this is that 60 that
doesn't move regardless of
price upward or downward in movement
those people aren't looking at the
day-to-day price what they've basically
said is i've acquired x
amount of bitcoin and i'm just going to
hold it for years
and every time somebody's done that
right if you bought bitcoin at any point
in the last 12 years and you held it
till today you are up in us dollar terms
now if we had this conversation 18
months ago couldn't say that
so it's all about not only the
acquisition
price if you will it's also when are you
looking at it
right because there was a point in 2017
you could have said the same thing but
in 18 you couldn't
and so i tend to think a lot about
humans are really really bad
at short-term uh decision-making
because we're so emotional especially
when something has a price tied to it
yeah so it's
in terms of our the strategies and
decision-making we should be long-term
and have like a regular
almost think like an algorithm that in
that in that kind of way
so i think you've tweeted that uh you
believe that bitcoin has a chance of
reaching one million i don't know what
it is currently i think it's five
which is incredible i
think i remember when it was at least in
the double digits i think i remember was
in the signal digits of a dollar
so the fact that it's across 50 is crazy
uh but uh you're even crazier apparently
thinking that it can reach a million
so do you think it's possible for it to
reach a million is there some kind of
transformative effects
we'll have to see first when might it
reach a million like
what are the signs that we would look
for what's required for it to reach a
million so let's just look at it from a
macro
perspective uh gold is a 10 trillion
dollar asset
and when you compare the technology of
gold to the technology of
bitcoin bitcoin is superior in every
single way right it's more
portable it's more divisible uh it's
more verifiable it's more scarce on
everything and so some people would
argue it's a 10x improvement some people
argue it's 100x improvement from a
technology standpoint
and so we don't need bitcoin to actually
kind of um capture the full 10x or 100x
improvement from a
market cap standpoint if bitcoin simply
captures
2x the value would be a 20 trillion
dollar market cap which would put
bitcoin at about a million dollars
right so kind of just from a macro
perspective if you have a 10x or 100x
improvement from a technology standpoint
and you directionally get some value
capture in that direction
you're hitting around a million or more
uh dollar price point
you can ask a quick question which is uh
what's the current market cap for
bitcoin
uh the current market cap's right around
a trillion just over a trillion dollars
and
you're saying gold is 10 trillion and uh
i'm sorry
where did you get the 20 trillion 20
trillion would just be 2x cold's market
cap
got it right so if it's a 10x technology
improvement let's just say it only
captures 2x the market cap
got it right and so again if it was to
capture just gold's market cap kind of
the equivalent
puts you around 500 000 right so you can
kind of see there's
bitcoin so if you capture the entirety
of the gold market
uh then it would be value of single
bitcoin uh the price of a single bitcoin
would be 500
000 okay to reach a million it would be
double that
that's what the 20 trillion comes from
correct got it so if you then
say to yourself okay how does the uh
the pricing um kind of cycles work right
or
the boom and bust cycles gold
is a very kind of linear type
supply schedule meaning that there is a
certain amount of gold that comes out of
the ground each year
the inter-year variation in that
incoming supply
is not much right maybe there's an extra
mining company that gets set up or a
couple of them
or maybe one goes out of business but
for the most part the kind of
inflationary
increase to the supply of gold is pretty
stagnant uh year over year
bitcoin has a very unique feature which
every four years
there is a programmatic supply shock
meaning that
uh in the beginning 50 bitcoin every 10
minutes was introduced into the supply
after four years of that happening every
10 minutes it was cut in half
so on a in a single moment it went from
50 to now it was 25.
four years every 10 minutes 25 got cut
in half again to 12 and a half and then
recently in may 2020 got cut to 6.25
when you have an asset that is
determined the price
based on supply and demand you normally
have two inputs to the equation
what is the supply and what is the
demand in an asset like gold
or a stock or anything else we have to
do our best
guess at the supply both the existing
supply and the incoming supply
and do our best guess at the demand and
we're actually pretty good at this a lot
of times in terms of directionally
saying it's going to go up or down and
here's kind of some price point
milestones
bitcoin is unique in that there's 100
verifiable proof
of the existing supply the total supply
and the incoming daily supply so we know
100 i can show you on the actual
blockchain
uh or in the code that there's 21
million bitcoin uh and that's all there
will ever be
i can show you that there's 18.6 million
give or take
uh bitcoin that actually are in
circulation today right now i can go all
the way back show you every single
transaction that's ever occurred since
january through 2009
and then i can show you on a daily basis
that 900 bitcoin a day are coming into
the circulating supply
and so when you have 100 confidence
because you can prove
the supply side of this equation you can
hold it constant
i know with 100 accuracy the supply side
so now i've reduced the mathematical
equation that i need to do to determine
price movements
to a 50 reduction i only have to worry
about demand i don't have to worry about
supply
and so when i look at demand i can do
all kinds of things i can take the
demand over the last 10 years and the
growth and just extrapolate it out i can
increase it i can decrease it whatever
but what you find is that these supply
shocks
lead to significant price appreciation
as the asset gets repriced because there
there's a supply shock to it
and so probably the best thing that i've
done over the last couple of years was
in 2019 i started to talk about the idea
that we were going to have both the
supply shock
and the demand shock in 2021
or i'm sorry in 2020. i didn't know when
this bull market that we were in was
gonna nobody knows right it's impossible
to time
these things but you could tell that we
were kind of at late stages of a cycle
there was inverted yield curves there
was re uh gyrations in the repo markets
a lot of ceos leaving their jobs you
know all this kind of stuff
and all i said was at some point when
the market turns over
the government's gonna have to step in
we are addicted to stimulus they're
gonna have to manipulate interest rates
down and they're gonna have to print
money
i had no clue that there was gonna be a
global pandemic
that they were gonna have to step in in
such an aggressive way and move rates
not down but down to zero
and that they not only were going to
print hundreds of billions but they
could print trillions of dollars
but the framework that i used to think
about this was when they
do that everyone is going to run
to store value assets they're going to
run to gold they're going to run the
bitcoin et cetera
and right as they do that it appears at
the same time there's going to be this
supply shock so you're going to get a
supply shock and a demand shock that are
both positive for the price and i call
it rocket fuel for bitcoin
well it happened and here we are i now
look for and i say okay
we are likely going to see a hundred
thousand bitcoin a hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin this year right at some
point i don't know when it happens but
we're moving in that city i think in
2021 we'll see a hundred thousand
that would be uh my most conservative
view uh i
i've said a hundred thousand dollars
since 2019 and people thought that was
insane and crazy and all stuff now i'm
the conservative guy in the room because
i stick with the hundred thousand
dollars and people are saying
you know multiples of that number here
uh so we'll see what happens but
but i think that there's still a lot of
room kind of to run from a u.s dollar
price standpoint
what is on the horizon is in 2024 we
will have another supply shock
and so that's what i think will carry us
to the million dollar bitcoin from six
to five to whatever
50 reduction yeah yeah and so that's
what i think
uh we'll basically when we get that's
that next supply shock that'll carry us
up over 100
or over a 1 million dollar bitcoin price
which
if historical examples persist and again
sometimes it's hard to use historical
examples to uh look at future
events um but if that happens we would
see a million dollars of bitcoin
by the end of 2026. after that wave
so 2024 basically is the supply shock
and within
you know 18 to 24 months you would see
the uh
the kind of top of the next market
hopefully without a coupling to the net
to another pandemic yes we would like to
do all of this without a
public health crisis so that would take
it to
would uh 20 trillion you don't have to
compare it to the dollar
essentially in some sense that the
dollar could also lose value i mean
there's a lot of kind of dynamics at
play here
now but like fundamentally there's going
to be a huge
move in your prediction of value into
into bitcoin i mean that's a fascinating
world to think about
uh i mean but i do have to kind of
ask you about the whole space of
technology there because
we're talking about the value of
security we're talking about the
the future which bitcoin will be at the
center of but from my perspective of
thinking how like i and others can build
technologies on top of
this kind of decentralized world i'm
thinking about different tech
different technologies out there
different cryptocurrencies out there
ethereum being one but there's a lot of
others
so i'd love to get your sort of ideas
about some of these but
so first let me ask you about what the
hell is [ __ ] coin
is this connected to uh to our previous
discussion of the meme
uh does [ __ ] coin cover basically all
coins that are not
bitcoin is it uh uh
mean is it a beautiful is this a mixture
of both
as with most things in life uh depends
who you ask um
the uh most um uh
kind of enthusiastic and uh uh
parts of the bitcoin community shitcoin
is anything else
right kind of if you ascribe to kind of
a maximalistic view of the world
should run be anything if you look at
people who i would say are bitcoin
proponents
uh yet see value in other things
[ __ ] coin may be the bottom half of the
other things
right so i think again it's really
important kind of who you
ask is how you'll get that answer so
there's tiers
and the way you divide those tiers might
be different depending who you ask
ultimately what it is is it's a meme
yeah and it's used to
uh articulate the idea that
whatever you want to put in that bucket
has no value so [ __ ] coin
are coins that have no value yeah uh
what is fascinating
about it and i think that again speaks
to the power of the bitcoin community
is uh there was congressional hearings a
couple of years ago
oh no and at one point uh a congressman
from ohio warren davidson who
was definitely open-minded and excited
about bitcoin
asked a an individual on the congress
floor
uh during testimony to uh talk about
these other coins and at one point
basically read into the
record the terminology of [ __ ] coin he
said the word [ __ ] coin
uh i i can't remember if he said it
first somebody else did it or if uh the
other person did and then he
um you know repeated it uh but he
definitely
he was trying to get that read into the
record yes uh for
sure and so uh yeah you can imagine
one again the meme speaking insolently
to the
bitcoin community was you know made him
very uh very well liked
uh but also too was um it does go
back to this idea almost of uh if you
and i sat down with 10 ceos
and we interviewed each one of them and
then we went in a room and we
deliberated and we said we have to pick
the person who's going to be the most
successful
one of the inputs not all the inputs but
one of the inputs would be who's the
person who
we believe has the best ability to raise
capital
recruit people and tell a story to the
world
that will get them to follow and so
somebody like elon would probably be the
best example of this
when you have decentralized products you
have no kind of
leader right in the sense of uh somebody
who is financially
uh ascribed to be that leader and kind
of the the executive decision maker
so what you have to do is you have to
look at these technologies in these
communities and say
well which volunteer teams or which
technologies have been able to coalesce
these groups around it
and in some way build the same level of
engagement
and protection and things like that and
so
you actually get tribalism but you also
get things like
[ __ ] coin because what it does is it's
not only a
kind of verbal attack towards uh
others it's a rallying cry for
internal what's so funny is that it was
started with the bitcoin community
talking about everybody but now you've
seen adoption in other communities who
use it
you know basically say well we're not a
[ __ ] coin it's the it's the next guy
yeah i mean the meaning to be honest
it's
it's one it's off it's sometimes misused
i think like with anything it's like
people adopt memes
that we used to be brilliant or still
brilliant
and they're just not good at using them
so they become
mean but when you do
with with grace it can tear down an
argument
and at the same time have like love and
respect underneath it i mean it's a
beautiful dance they have to be good at
like you know people just can suck at
communication and even
uh like even a powerful weapon like a
meme in the wrong hands
just uh fires in a way that doesn't get
anything done
but this is like a war of humor and
memes it's kind of fascinating exactly
like you formulated that there's
asymmetry of power so you have to have
guerilla warfare in this internet
game especially when there's no leader
like you said in a distributed culture
here that is um is really important i
think is from a society standpoint
we've become very soft and very kind of
coddling
and not in um not in a way that's like i
think people take this argument like too
far sometimes but what i mean by that is
um
it's almost like if you're the person
who holds somebody accountable
you become the bad person right if
you're the person who
um says hey you know that's wrong you're
the bad person
right and so in a world where i think in
this kind of influencery you know all
positive if you have any negative
you know feedback or constructive
criticism like you're the bad person
uh it's the ultimate echo chamber right
and so i think that what the bitcoin
world does
and some crazy crazy way to look at it
is bitcoin is ultimately about truth
yeah
not about narrative not about feelings
or emotion it's math yeah you look at a
blockchain
and you can prove something or you can't
and so naturally people who are
attracted to that have a very similar
approach in life
yeah right they say hey you made x claim
prove it and as you can imagine you know
a great example is like the financial
media
meets bitcoiners and it's a bloodbath
right in kind of the the arena of ideas
because
what do they do the financial media is
used to the soft
you know opinion pieces et cetera and
bitcoiners show up and they're like
uh here's data point a b and c here's
example one two and three and you're
wrong
and then all they yell and scream about
is like uh i'm wrong i'm wrong i'm wrong
like
you can't say i'm wrong and like no like
disprove what i just said
and so you get in this like very very
weird it's fascinating it's a
fascinating benefit but
i i do want to say it's it i've been
watching this
it's kind of interesting i think that
the pursuit of truth through like
tearing down bad ideas can be done with
grace
and to do it with grace requires a lot
of skill
like what people don't realize about
this agreement
they think that disagreement is easy
like
they they see the the the lies or the
inaccuracies in the statement
and and they just think they can say
wrong
yes you can say that but if you want to
be effective
it requires great skill like you look at
i don't know
um a beautiful uh
verbal [ __ ] poster which is christopher
hitchens right
it requires a lot of skill through your
words
to tear down an argument to criticize
and to take a step towards truth uh
what i'm disheartened by internet
culture like the negative
side is people don't put a lot of effort
in their tear downs like into your [ __ ]
posting into your memes
you should put effort and see it as a
skill that you want to if you want to be
a part of this culture
you want to uh get good at it like any
skill
to 10 000 hours like get improve
deliberate practice self-criticism all
of those things
just because you're anonymous doesn't
mean
you won't get deep joy and actually have
an impact on the world if you get
good at [ __ ] posting but but but i think
this is
really really important right because
you're right in that uh it's all about
intention versus action
if your intention is to uh tell somebody
that they are wrong
in an effort to get them to see the
truth yes
that's very different than if your
intention is to tell someone they're
wrong and hurt their feelings yes
right and so when you can unpack and
tension in action
you really quickly can tell what
somebody ultimately is trying to
accomplish
i also think that one of the craziest
things that i've seen play out
is uh memes when i use that term i'm not
just talking about like a static photo
right when i'm talking about these
elaborate
uh kind of edited videos and kind of all
this stuff
um when done right
it is uh the most articulate
way to deliver a blunt message and it's
done in such a way that is humorous and
entertaining
yet really hammers the point home and so
it's a skill set that many people don't
have i don't make those i'm
assuming you don't make them either
right i see them i share the ones that i
like
right uh but it does take practice
and you can tell look there's people who
are fantastic meme lords
right and there are people who
absolutely suck at it
and it's like anything it's just how
good are you at communicating
and i've heard the idea a bunch of times
so i don't know who to kind of credit
for it but
uh whether it's emojis it's gifs it's
memes whatever
this is the extension and evolution of
just hieroglyphics
right yeah like like we have been doing
this for literally
centuries it's just that now we're doing
it on the internet and you can press a
button and go to millions and millions
of people immediately
uh but speaking of memes what the heck
do you think is
up with elon musk talking about dogecoin
a lot
sort of uh from the cryptocurrency
community i
uh from i've been talking to a lot of
sort of technologists
i guess and reading papers on
cryptocurrency
it's like nobody really sees
dogecoin as a revolutionary crypto
technology
a lot of people talk about security
issues there's a bunch of issues it has
nevertheless you did say that money
is the kind of social construct right
and uh elon musk's combination of humor
and brilliant engineering in the various
companies he runs
combines to create a kind of value
and excitement behind dogecoin it's like
what is it he says that the most
amusing outcome is is the most likely
kind of idea
which sounds silly but there could be
like profound truth to it
it's like what do you make of deutsche
coin philosophically
or technically is is it possible that
deutsche coin will overtake bitcoin and
run the entire
run the entire world i can't even
because it could happen
it could happen but what uh if there's
any serious way to answer that question
well we have to start with uh techno
king
of tesla yeah and master of coin
as they are so articulately called in
the latest sec filing
because he officially changed his title
techno king yes techno king of tesla
and now the cfo's new uh title is a
master of coin
and so uh when you have a sense of humor
yeah and frankly uh a level of uh
self-confidence and uh an element
of uh an appreciation for irony in the
world
dogecoin is actually one of the least
crazy things that you could talk about
when you're willing to go to techno king
of tesla master of coin
uh and all this stuff and so i think
that
elon uh doesn't get enough credit
frankly for his understanding of
internet culture
understanding of memes and understanding
of frankly human psychology and
marketing
and so in some crazy way every time he
talks about dogecoin
it's a rallying cry for an entire
generation of kids
industry in terms of cryptocurrencies
and digital technologies
but this is the flag yeah
and this is the thing that he can yell
and scream about
and tweet about without worry of
punishment
so he could be talking about bitcoin he
could be talking about cryptocurrency
but that's not going to be uh as
beautifully
humorous and whatever the hell internet
culture is as
dogecoin he's finding the right language
he's speaking the language of the people
of the in the digital age if you want to
reach weird people
yeah you can't be serious and most
people are weird
the the masses are weird so he's
speaking to the masses
yeah and the techno king and even
further than that i think is
he essentially is um he's using
dogecoin as a way to say
i'm doing this because i can yeah he
couldn't do it
with securities he couldn't do it with
certain types of other assets right
like i almost look at this like a venn
diagram what's the thing that a bunch of
people know about
care about thinkers funny whatever and
also
overlay that with the things that like
he could actually talk about they won't
get in trouble for
that's a big fu to the sec i could see
the
the people just freaking out i i mean i
love it
but um i i don't know if i would have
the guts to do it myself
but i i think he's an inspiration to a
lot of us to be like well maybe you
should grow the guts
when you're the techno king you can do
whatever you want right
[Laughter]
and i mean that's something to aspire to
is to be the techno king in your own
little world
if you also think about it in the sense
of uh when you're somebody on a mission
to create interplanetary
life yeah when you're trying to solve
a or put a dent in the climate crisis
or create electric vehicles and be the
first american company and you know
however long
frankly the sec or
other things in your life that just
don't you don't ascribe that much
importance to compared to those things
they're almost uh nuisances and
that's scary i think for shareholders of
a company when
the person that you're trusting to lead
you to the promised land and create
shareholder value
doesn't put value on certain things but
at the same time
i always look at it as a tug of war how
much of the actions of what he's doing
and calling attention to actually
changed the way
that regulators lawmakers politicians
countries whatever act he may not be
able to say
do x i'm the techno king and they go do
it
but with every step he makes he
changes some of their behavior and so i
think that it's um
a really kind of game of like 3d chess
that frankly i'm not privy to right i'm
kind of watching from the sidelines and
uh figuring out alongside everybody else
but i also don't think that it's just
elon
uh bought a bunch of dogecoin and tweets
about it because he thinks he's going to
a dollar and he's gonna you know make
money right like i don't think
i don't think it's an economic argument
as to why he's so interested in it i
think it's much more
uh it's almost like meta message
for a lot of other stuff yeah he's kind
of uh trying to break apart
internet communication from first
principles like he does so many other
problems it's kind of fascinating to
watch i know he's been
uh he's he's taught me quite a bit about
communication
and uh at least for me
it's been liberating to not give a
[ __ ] about the old school way of things
i've been always bothered by a place i
deeply admire which is mit
but there's problems the bureaucracies
and hierarchies that hold back
innovation brilliant minds
and in that sense doge is a kind of
fu to the system that's kind of positive
but also uh kind of uh
but it was also an fu so in that
sense i think elon has a perspective on
the world that's similar to bitcoin
folks
which i really like which is like
thinking long
term it's how visionaries think it's
like how will
if i take these ideas what
and the ideas hold true
what will the world look like in 20 30
50 years
and think about everything in that way
yeah i like
bezos view which is uh is essentially
how do you minimize regret how do you
accelerate your life mentally and go to
80 90 100 150 years whatever we end up
being you know fortunate enough to live
to and then look backwards
yes and say this decision that i'm gonna
make i have two
options which one is going to be the one
that i least regret
and if you continue to make decisions
that way
one you have that long-term view kind of
built in because you're working
backwards
two you are ultimately going to optimize
for
minimal regret but also three is
even if you only look for 10 years
that's much much further than most
people do
and so it gives you a significant
advantage and i think that um
bitcoin has kind of this like um you
know proxy for time
as we talked about inter-plant planetary
travel
where there's multiple steps from
creating a reusable rocket to landing it
to
you know all the stuff all the way to
simple things just like
if you're simply trying to figure out
where the world's going to be 30 years
from now
you know bill gates says that we
overestimate what we can do in one year
underestimate what we can do in 10. well
to me it's a kind of degree of
uh mistake if you will 10 years maybe
you're off by 10
well if that line of progress continues
20 years you may be off by
100 and 30 years you may be off by a
thousand percent
right like almost the further you go out
the more inaccurate you become
and so i think that people who
want to iterate their way to success
right that's a common thing in like the
startup world
end up actually following
kind of the breadcrumbs to where the
world is taking them
but people like an elon musk a jeff
bezos
a jack dorsey all the way down the line
all these innovators
they actually say to themselves there is
a point in time
in the future where there's a world i
want to construct
and then they go and they construct it
regardless of
the short-term iterations and incentives
it is just they're driving towards that
point and i think that it's this whole
idea of having this like
you know kind of set vision and this uh
refusal
to kind of move or budge off of that
it's what makes them special
one of the things that garnered a lot of
excitement in the crypto
community is nfts i
i have no idea really the
depths the fundamental technological
philosophical depths of the second
of this technology whether this is just
like a little bit of a fad
or if there's some deep lessons to learn
whether it's bitcoin or cryptocurrency
in general about it
do you have thoughts about like the long
lasting fundamental aspects of nfts
i think there's probably both things
happening fad and things to learn
right and um if we just start with like
what is an nft it's a non-fungible token
meaning that
um there's no fungibility and
fungibility is a
fancy word i always describe it as if i
took a hundred dollar bill and i put it
on the table with a bunch of other
hundred dollar bills and we mixed them
up
and i just grabbed a hundred dollar bill
and left i'm no worse as long as they're
all
you know uh official hundred dollar
bills because as long as i have 100
500 i don't need that exact same bill
back so that means that those hundred
dollar bills are fungible
non-fungible would be like art if i took
a picasso and i put it down on the table
and you brought three artists that no
one's ever heard of before and we mixed
them up
and i just took any random piece of art
it wasn't the picasso i lose because the
picasso is really important there right
so the
non-fungibility is important in art what
these non-fungible tokens essentially
are doing
is they are creating scarcity
and originality in a digital environment
and what i mean by that is um take a
music file
if i had a music file and you wanted it
you said send it to me
i press send it essentially creates a
copy and you get one music file i get
another
we don't care you can listen to the
music i can listen to music we're super
happy
if i instead though have a digital file
that entire premise is based on scarcity
and i hit send and you get a copy and i
keep the original or you get the
original i get a copy
there's a problem and so ultimately
what i think is playing out with nfts is
it's a technology
regardless of where it plays out from
blockchains or
what in communities or environments that
just brings
true digital scarcity to the internet
and so naturally what do people do they
look at the legacy world and they say
well what's scarce there that has value
how do we bring that to the digital
world so art is a perfect example right
and
you know frankly last year i started to
look at this because it felt like this
was going to be really really big
and the conclusion i came to was
just as bitcoin is going to be bigger
than gold right the digital
application of something is going to be
bigger than the analog application
the same thing is going to be true in
art the digital art world is going to be
bigger than the traditional art world
people think that sounds crazy at first
until you start to realize
it's very very similar the yard is more
portable
it can be divisible right it's got a
larger demand market in terms of the
internet rather than an
auction right all this kind of stuff
when you display it
it can have motion and music and all of
these
aspects to it that are better than the
traditional art
what the traditional art market has that
the digital art market has not had
is the narrative narrative-based world
scarcity kind of in a digital sense
and so what i think the entire world
is going through right now is an
exploration of how do we use this
technology
to create new things
frankly we're not going to be good at it
for a while and so
the only place i've really focused on is
digital art itself
and i've always been interested in art
but i wasn't going to go buy a painting
and hang it on the wall
right in the sense of that's how i was
going to store value
what i find fascinating though is that i
now can take
that concept which most of the
wealthiest people in the world
have a significant portion some you know
some people have 20 percent in terms of
you know number of billionaires
20 of their wealth is in art and you can
bring to this digital realm
which is much more um kind of natural to
a digital native
and so the best way to know how to
describe the importance is
imagine a serial number being placed on
something
take the eiffel tower the only eiffel
tower that has value is the first one
every replica of it regardless of size
location
you know who made it where they sent it
they have no value
eiffeltower001 is the most important and
so i think that's ultimately what we're
starting to see here
and what we're looking at is probably
one percent of what it's going to grow
into
you're bullish on us you're saying it
could grow into something for
one percent it could grow into something
significant like all kinds of different
applications
strip away all the applications right
now and just think about
is digital scarcity going to be
important on the internet right moving
all the things that are scarce in the
physical world into digital space
us trying to figure out which things can
be moved and not and also there's things
in the digital space just like you're
saying that don't exist in the physical
world that
might also benefit from gaining scarcity
like you know people are i guess
creating nfts out of like tweets
or whatever so like you're you have you
have a fun twitter account
you know you could say like you could
put value to a single tweet and then be
able to invest in it and trade it and
buy parts of it and all those kinds of
things you know you can invest in people
you can invest in
you know art can be defined broadly as
any kind of creation right in in some
sense
this whole idea of scarcity can overtake
the entirety
of the digital world it can like consume
the all of the markets we see as
financial markets and just turn
everything into a market
well so if i if i take you on like a i
don't know
10 year fast forward yeah and i paint a
picture of
something today that seems absolutely
insane but there's early signs that
people are building this and let's just
give them the benefit of the doubt that
some of the early iterations will work
and some of or most of them won't
there's a world where you and i are
participating in a digital economy
in a virtual world where uh whether it
is a piece of art
it is a digital sculpture it is a
digital
skin from a video game it is a digital
good
that we purchased somewhere online
and we bring it and we display it in a
digital museum
or a virtual museum and so now all of a
sudden
you can charge people for entry you can
consign
digital goods it's the replication of
what happens in the analog world
now just in digital and when you do that
what you do is you take
the addressable markets of these assets
or these mechanisms
and they explode in the digital realm
and so now all of a sudden
how fast does the human race
accelerate when it comes to human
production
intelligence learning all in the digital
output
let's just if i said to you 20 years ago
i'm going to give you a global education
it means i'm going to take you and i'm
going to physically move you
to geography after geography after
geography it's going to take time
it's going to take resources and
ultimately it's going to take lots of
effort
if i now said to you hey i'm going to
transport you
in this virtual world to multiple
geographies
but you're going to experience it in
this virtual
uh world and you're going to have
digital goods that you can take
from economy to economy or from location
to location
all of a sudden you may get maybe you
get 90 of that you don't get a hundred
percent of the same value we get ninety
percent of the value
but you can do it at a much faster pace
and so in a six month period you've
actually
made three times the progress than you
would have
if you had to do in the physical world
so that's where i think we're heading so
[Music]
so there's digital art being displayed
in the digital
museum and people are being charged for
access and perhaps we plug in our senses
which means we start to operate more and
more in a virtual reality
augmented reality virtual reality way
with this digital world
and increasingly go into this world
basically
lived most of our productive and uh
social lives in this digital world
and increasingly essentially create a
simulation
uh where the biological basis is just
there to
sustain the brain that's used to operate
in the in the virtual world
uh taking us back to the original when
we started talking about war
i wonder what conflict looks like in
that world
that uh the people who are born today
maybe will be fighting wars
in the space in in that museum world
in that digital world remember what i
said we're moving from a world
of conflict surrounded and determined by
bombs bullets and soldiers to a
battlefield that is determined by
war of information and cyber
capabilities
and so in that virtual world is it
about death and destruction of
human life in the physical analog world
or will it become more important to
attack or defend
virtual property and virtual life and
you know some level of virtual
sovereignty
in my opinion the latter is more likely
and so what you start to understand is
well
what do you truly value in your life
is it the physical analog materialistic
consumptive
goods or is it virtual
and in many cases something as simple as
the ability to connect with somebody
is really important and so one of the
most disruptive
combative violent things that a country
may do to another country in the future
simply take down the internet
and put people in isolation yeah i don't
need to physically harm you if i can
psychologically harm you
i don't need to terrifying yeah i don't
need to
actually convince you through
a monopoly on violence on physical
violence
what if i can psychologically change the
way you see the world
through misinformation through all sorts
of
nefarious activities and i think that
you know the united states has been
struggling with this idea over the last
couple of years in the political arena
but what happens when it starts to come
to other aspects of our life
and i think it's very likely it's almost
obviously likely that we're moving into
the digital world
the one of the features of the digital
world
is that artificial intelligence systems
can operate with much more power and
a frictionless way in that world
currently as we understand it it's hard
to build robots
that operate at scale and do like
arbitrary large amount of impact
damage or positive in the physical world
it's much easier to do in the digital
world do you have do you ever think
about
ai systems just swimming about
uh doing extraordinarily powerful
destructive things in the digital world
is that something of a concern to you
or is this something into a very distant
future
i think a lot of artificial intelligence
is
uh in the name it's simply the
replication of human intelligence
at scale automated
and pr and program programmatic meaning
that
in the analog world you could go hire a
thousand employees
or in you know an amazon case hire
millions of employees
and set a mission or a goal and push
them to go do that
that requires recruiting retention
training resources all that stuff
in the virtual world or in this digital
economy
what if you can just program the
resources and gain the same leverage
and do it at scale and do it in a very
programmatic way
and then have them actually make
decisions
in a way that doesn't require you to
have thought of every single
potential scenario or edge case that's
ultimately what we're talking about we
talk about artificial intelligence right
and so when you look at that when
technology's created
everyone uses it for good or bad but
both get used
right and so whether we're talking about
cell phones beepers the internet
guns whatever it's always used for good
and bad
the big question is and i think that you
know yourself and many other people have
rightfully
said this is the question really becomes
is the negative and nefarious
uses of this inadvertent potentially
or does it actually come from a
malicious person it's the intention
militias
and to me that's what i i don't know
enough you know much more about this and
there's plenty of other people who do as
well
but i do think that there will be
nefarious actors and malicious people
but we're going to treat them the same
way we've always treated people who use
technology poorly
right we're going to understand it we're
going to identify it we're going to
control it and then we're going to end
up
reversing it or preventing that from
doing that it's the inadvertent things
that i think are actually the most
dangerous
because when you have something that can
think for itself
and there is no way to leverage a
monopoly on violence
for control it's a very scary thing
and it can i mean the the thing that's
scary to me is that
it can scale arbitrarily so it can
outnumber humans very quickly
even if it's dumber than humans and so
i don't know if we're able to reason
about a world
like let's look at the physical analog
where all of a sudden
uh let's talk about something kind of
like humans but dumber than humans like
chimps
okay imagine that all of a sudden chimps
could multiply
arbitrarily quickly and you could have
like
a trillion chimps the next day
when when you only had maybe a million
the day before
like how does that world look different
where the [ __ ] did all these
chimps come from and they like and then
we can we can pretend to be like well
let's hope
the chimps like don't get violent
because they they don't seem to get
violent
when the resources aren't constrained
but like we don't know
and the problem is it all starts by
building that first
chip multiplier device and everyone's
like okay yeah there's a lot of good
applications you want
you know you can make all kinds of
arguments
for why you have more chimps maybe they
can help you out around the house or
something like that
in the physical space but
ultimately it's the unintended
consequences that you're referring to is
you don't know what's gonna happen i'm
really worried about
dumb ai agents uh
like having impact when they're
multiplied
to a million to a billion and are
allowed to operate in the digital space
especially as we clearly are moving more
and more
of our lives into the digital space so
it's kind of terrifying because we you
know a lot of people are terrified
or like concerned about super
intelligent systems
i think i'm definitely much more
concerned about
super dumb systems at scale that that's
terrifying
i always think about um the inadvertent
but as you were talking what it made me
think of is
also the irreversible irreversible right
so it's one thing if there's
uh inadvertent negative impact
but we have reversibility built into a
system and we can fix our mistakes
yeah i think the really scary part is
when you overlay inadvertent mistakes
with the
irreversible aspect of it and therefore
humans have no control yeah if you if
you have the trillion chimps
you can't they're not gonna like it when
you try to start killing them off
uh all right but back to bitcoin
those chimps in the bitcoin community
anytime you bring up chimps
somebody will say joe rogan entered the
chat can i ask you
about sort of learning about bitcoin
books and resources do you have
an amazing podcast that's not just about
bitcoin or cryptocurrency it's about
everything including life but you do
have a lot of really amazing
conversations about this whole
world digital world but you oh obviously
you also
have a newsletter that's incredible on
sub stack
and and um
but do you have recommendations maybe it
would be great if you could talk about
first of all your podcast
and the news newsletter but also other
resources that you recommend people
should check out
in order to learn about bitcoin yeah so
the podcasts and uh email are like the
two
most selfish things i do because the
podcast is a way for me to learn from
other people
so i get them to come on and tell me all
the things they're thinking about and i
get asked some questions
what's it called by the way uh just a
pomp podcast
and so in doing that um it really
is informative for me and i think that
my whole goal is just like if i'm
learning other people will be learning
and then the email i read it every
morning because it forces me to
collect my thoughts and actually
articulate them in somewhat of a
coherent way
and so it's just something that um is
like a practice that i probably would do
even if no one read it
and then by being able to publish it uh
what does it do it elicits you know
both the good and bad responses and so
people will let me know if they think
i'm an idiot and they'll
usually not respond if they think that
it's something smart and so um those two
things are uh really
um educational for me and and i think
kind of forced me to uh to be able to
articulate a lot of ideas
but a lot of what i share or learn on
those things come from these other
resources so
i'm definitely subscribing people should
subscribe but what are
bitcoin resources books that you
recommend
i think you gotta start with bitcoin
standard uh that one to me feels like
uh it really lays out the picture nicely
um
there is uh bitcoin uh money you can't
[ __ ] with uh it's written by our friend
jason williams
uh as you can imagine it's basically
what it talks about
uh there's another book layered money um
that's written by nick who uh who's done
a grant a
great job kind of laying it out there's
a book
called bitcoin in black america written
by a guy isaiah jackson
and he basically lays out the argument
for why the black community
can benefit in a asymmetric way from
something like bitcoin
um and there's a whole bunch more i'm
gonna forget them all
there's the uh i think it's called the
cost of tomorrow a guy uh jeff booth
uh jeff booth wrote it um and just
if you get on twitter basically you're
gonna see all these books flying around
um but i do have to say that uh from a
psychological concept uh or
philosophical
uh concept the number one book that i've
ever read uh that aligns with bitcoin
ethos but doesn't say a word about
bitcoin
is a book called the dao of capital by
mark spitznagel
and so what he essentially does is he
just reiterates over and over and over
again
long-term thinking outliers disruption
all the stuff and so he's a guy who he
runs a fund
that essentially they just do uh tail
risk hedging
and so in you know march or february of
they're up like four thousand percent
right
by the way they pretty much lose money
you know
for eight nine years then that happens
and so uh
but they're still one of the best
performing funds if you look at it over
you know years and years and so it's
just this mindset of
uh everyone is so short-term focused and
so i think it's just a great reminder to
long-term thinking
uh and also i mean i've gotten quite a
bit of value just reading the papers
that's perhaps more like for technical
folks there's quite an active research
community
and also going back to the original
white paper and just
original documents old school old school
still
uh what uh like what a few years ago
really interesting to think about
to look at what people were thinking
about because
the the principles are carried through
uh with uh other cryptocurrencies as
well like it's it's all
it's all there even in the early
documents so
it's kind of fascinating to see that
whole history from if you're more like
tech savvy
and like you said twitter is actually an
interesting place if you can look up
past
all the [ __ ] coin talk uh it's a it's a
fascinating place for news and resources
is there books outside of all of this
cryptocurrency sort of
technical fiction philosophical that an
impact on your life
because you've you have interests that
are all over the place is there
something that um
you would recommend to others so doubt
capital is definitely probably my
favorite book
um books that have been impactful i read
when i was 20 actually sitting in the
desert of iraq um
rich dad poor dad think and grow rich
and the richest man in babylon
and i don't think i took a single thing
and like
implemented it from like an execution
standpoint uh but it was a complete
shift in mentality and understanding a
relationship with money
and just kind of what i wanted to do
with my life and stuff like that so i
think those three books i read them in
succession
were really impactful um and then i
think one of the best books probably
ever written
is uh i think it's called when breath
becomes air um or air becomes breath i
can't remember
uh but it's basically a doctor or a
medical professional
who's dying and he essentially writes
about
the experience and thoughts and kind of
all the stuff and
i think that it's just one of these
things where if you said to me you know
what's the number one thing i took out
of my experience in iraq
that's a book like that also gives you
is we're all going to die
right and you and i can want to be as
immortal as we want but at some point
we're going to die
and so it really does kind of focus you
on
time being that scarce asset and use it
for enjoyment and happiness
more so than anything else and i think
that's part of your message and it's a
great one
do you do you think do you like
literally meditate on your own mortality
i necessarily think i uh meditate on it
as much as um
are you afraid of death were you afraid
of death when you're in iraq i mean if
you're coming face to face with it
are you afraid of death today no i i
think that it was just one of these
things where like
if you fixate on something and you worry
about it
then to at least to me like you become
uneasy about it and so after an
experience
like going to war i think that
everything is just
so not important compared to that right
like when i came back i remember
uh going back into the college
environment and like things people were
worried about i was like
listen let me explain to you you know
what the real world's like right
but i think even today right if you talk
to people who know me really well
i don't get worked up about a lot of
stuff i don't get you know in either
direction good or bad
uh anything because ultimately it just
comes down to
if that's the final result let's enjoy
it
it's fascinating to ask you because this
reformulation of
money essentially buying time
and uh you know there's the old
question of does money buy happiness
do you think money can buy happiness
in the context of money being able to
buy time
or is happiness something else that is
beyond all of this
when people talk about this question i
think that they really focus on
money as a means to getting
materialistic things
so they want a big house they want a
boat they want a fast car
they want you know whatever they think
that's the stuff that will make them
happy
what i think about it is if you have
resources
you can have time and if you have time
and you spend it the way that you want
to spend it
then that's ultimately happiness so i
always say to people if you think that
money doesn't
buy you happiness what if i told you
that if you had more money you could
spend more time with your family
it reframes it yeah and now is all about
i want to do certain things in life but
there's a lot of people who spend their
life
not doing those things because they feel
the need to
pursue economic means as a way to
provide a living or whatever and so i
explained that i said listen
in my opinion again it's my opinion it's
what makes me happy
if i can leverage financial resources to
create more time to do the things i like
i'm happier might not work for everybody
but like that's what works for me
and so there's this element of like i
don't care what other people think if
they like that or not because
they're not me right like like there's
almost this element of like you got to
figure out what works for you and if it
works for me then like
no i think that resonates that will
resonate with a lot of people i think
that's a brilliant reframing of it
that said you kind of imply there's a
there's a reason behind this whole
existence of ours there's a meaning to
it
so let me ask what is the meaning of
life
anthony do you think about these
ridiculous big questions
that have no answer every once in a
while or do you just enjoy the [ __ ] out
of every day
i answer it in a way that um isn't meant
to be
accurate it's meant to um
be the right answer for me which is
ultimately
you know i talk to a lot of people who
always ask like what's the what are you
doing why are you doing this
it's to be happy and the reason why
i think of it that way is i've got a
friend jonathan geller who talks about
uh
you know enough being enough and
recently he talked about it in the
um context of bitcoin and so bitcoiners
are have two things any bitcoiner if you
talk to them they believe the same two
things one
they don't want the us dollar price to
go up because they actually want to
acquire more bitcoin
right and then like once they feel like
they've got enough but two is no matter
how much they only
think that they don't own enough and
they want to acquire more
and so at some point you say to yourself
what is enough and i think that the
whole meaning of life
is to understand kind of
what your level of satisfaction is and
for some people that's a monetary thing
some people that's a freedom of time
thing
for some people it's an impact thing
whatever but just understanding that's
important
and then going and accomplishing it and
what i've found is that
the people who i know who have done this
and been intentional about it
they accomplish it on a much shorter
timeline than people who don't
right there's some people who start
thinking about when they're 60 well
naturally you're not going to accomplish
it before you're 60 if you start
thinking about it at 60.
people who are thinking about it earlier
can do it and so i think that's really
it for me it's just like the meaning of
life is to enjoy it
the way i think about it that's because
it's a really nice formulation
i i almost like to sort of oscillate
back and forth so majority of the time
it's spent at the moment enough is
enough of gratitude
basically being content with where
you're at like deeply appreciative of
every moment and all the bitcoin
whatever bitcoin you have being deeply
appreciative
and that being enough and then some
fraction of time
perhaps it shrinks as you get older
that's maybe there's an optimal
trajectory there but
some fraction of time is spent being
like deeply self-critical
and nothing is enough nothing you've
ever done is worth anything it's the
marvel minsky said like the secret to
success
is hating everything you've ever done so
like that mode of just hating
everything you've ever done and just
like trying to improve trying to make
stuff better
nothing's enough it's never enough that
kind of stuff and then oscillating back
and forth like
you don't have to have the same
algorithm operating throughout the day
you could just like oscillate back and
forth
and maybe reserve that gratitude part
the chill part to when you're hanging
out with family and friends and loved
ones
and then when you're like alone or maybe
a work
is that the madman comes out kind of
thing i also think it's um
kind of purpose driven in the sense of
there's a lot of people who have the
uh i need to do more but in a somewhat
altruistic way
so they're you know take elon as an
example
the idea of colonizing mars
sure if he is successful he will be very
rich
i don't think you or i or many people
believe he's doing it for the money
right there's a lot of other things he
could do that'd be much easier that
would make him tons of money
and so in some weird way he has enough
because he's able to free himself from
the constraints
of i need to acquire more resources and
he can focus on what is the thing that i
want to work on regardless of money
and so in that pursuit that is
non-economic
you can be as selfish as you want
because ultimately you're not tied back
to
this like measurement tool and so it's
this
uh again like altruistic non-monetary
purpose and i think that there's a lot
of people who spend their whole life
looking for that and they don't know
what it is
and so again some people may not think
of it that
way but if you can find something to do
that
you win i don't think there's a better
way to end it anthony i'm a huge fan
it's a huge honor that you waste all
this time with me today
uh i you know i thank you for just
educating the world for for teaching me
uh
inspiring me to learn more about this
new set of technologies that
look like they have a potential to
change transform
all of human civilization so thank you
for coming today and thank you for being
who you are
absolutely thank you so much for having
me thanks for listening to this
conversation with anthony pompliano
and thank you to our sponsors there gun
muscle recovery device
sun basket meal delivery service
expressvpn
and indeed hiring website click their
links to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from mahatma gandhi
freedom is not worth having if it
doesn't include
the freedom to make mistakes
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time